aujourd'hui le podcast est sponsorisé
par police ligue 1 le sommeil c'est
important c'est primordial à une bonne
hygiène de vie bien manger réduire le
niveau de stress et le sommeil par
l'activité physique
tout cela est important mais bien dormir
le syphon pilon vient de changer l'heure
ça bouleverse un petit peu nos cycles de
sommeil alors c'est important d'avoir
une bonne hygiène a ce côté ce niveau le
coucher bhutto reposez vous bien avoir
un bon matelas bien bon oreiller
ça change tout ouais je sais pas
exactement c'est quand la dernière fois
vous avez changé votre date l'homme et
pensez-y pour de vrais mots chic j'ai
conservé pendant ben trop longtemps
vieux matelas qui était rendu tout
dégueulasse pour plein de raisons
notamment le fait que ça faisait trop
longtemps que je l'avais fait en ce
moment il fait noir à cinq erreurs tant
envie de roullens petite boule dans ton
lien caché que moi j'ai envie souvent
mais roland petit bol dans mon lit puis
je passe beaucoup de temps dans mon lit
surtout surtout l'hiver dans le fond
qu'en sortant du bernet un petit peu le
fait que rien de mieux qu'un nouveau ma
clope et police lit pont une politique
de s'ennuie décès sans en huile c'est
quasiment le tiers de ton en effet que
le temps d'essayer cent fois ton matelas
ou plus tu es decies 2010 y est soi même
si je travaille dans mon lit je pense
vraiment trop de temps dans mon lit pour
ce fameux prend un bon matelas exact
puissant du décès puis si vous ne
l'aimez pas y reviennent le chercher
chez vous qui utilisent les matelas il
jette pas poubelle il danse addmd et des
organismes caritative caritatif pardon
partout au canada fec les matelas sont
pas gaspillés y reprennent ils donnent à
des gens qui en ont besoin
c'est vraiment hot pippa lee s'est
évidemment compagnie dc on les aime y
encourage le studio est encore jacques
podcasts et encourage tout ce qu'on aime
dans le fond là on a un code promo pour
autres pour 25% of sur tout sauf les
sommiers le code promo cnsf 25
c'est valide jusqu'au 23 novembre fait
que si vous voulez vous reposer comme
dom se repose
allez voir ça merci gang boss libre oh
oui y est une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
venir sans filtre le podcast où on parle
de ce qu'ont vécu nos invités date si tu
cherches quentin avec moi doom plantes
si vous voulez nous encourager le pq on
nous le répète à chaque fois mais le
peten c'est la plateforme où est ce que
on a fait vous pouvez le plus
directement encouragé sans fil podcast
après chaque podcasts ont fait encore
moins de filtres parce qu'on discute du
podcast convient de faire fait que du
contenu exclusif aux membres et une
allée voir sur la description et d'un an
fait le lien il part donc dans la
description du podcast ci nomme cette
semaine on a reçu un vétéran du podcast
au québec
jean thomas jobin un humoriste qu'on
adore ont complètement décalé vous le
connaissez de toute façon ça a été super
le fun ça a été cependant aborder sur
des sujets aussi parfois sérieux parfois
complètement loufoque on a parlé
beaucoup trop longtemps de pilosité
faciale plus hésiter dorsale d'entretien
aussi d'entretien d'autres régions
d'aborder ce chacun ses petits rituels
d'entrée si je raconte comment bob le
chef français à m'acheter une tondeuse à
poils de nez complètement révolutionné
ma vie certes en baisse une tondeuse
nasa temps de navarre et sursis
également
on a parlé
parler d'occupation double aussi
gentiment qui est peu un si grand fan
mais quand même on l'a abordé le sujet
son analyse notre analyse des situations
qui se fait de télé réalité grand fan de
télé réalité sous verre pour ceux qui le
connaissent savent sont une obsession
absolue pour se réfugier en fait poser
les questions penses-tu qu'un jour tout
va participer à son aveu et vous verrez
ça la presse pour la réponse reste et
puis enfin des podcasts on est devenu un
petit peu sur les attentats tragiques de
la ville de québec que vous le savez mon
ph au milieu de québec
ça nous a beaucoup bouleversé saint
bouleverse encore c'est vraiment d'une
tristesse absolue c'est difficile à
comprendre
puis j'aimerais juste qu'on donne au mot
sympa si nos condoléances aux victimes
et à leurs familles c'est important
effectivement c'est toujours de succès
avec un call to action mais écoutez le
sien top up qu'à s'abonner par les amis
puis bombe à castres boycott
[Musique]
jean-thomas salut bonjour merci d'être
là fait plaisir commence à vous ça va
bien puis faisant ça revient un peu
fatiguée - lyon s'était lassé les
élections américaines pour un mot si je
me suis réveillé en sursaut deux fois
pendant à domicile cinq pattes avant du
mât dorment cette époque là il y avait
des experts optimise la perspective d'un
pilote je me réveillais cerveau super
gros à guy whittaker ma tchéquie cnn
c'est un entraîneur satisfait car ok on
en apprenait plus en même temps mon
cerveau est un peu embrouillé et puis ça
a pris une méthode demeure à marc
endormi puis à 6h15 j'ai fait la même
affaire que j'ai comme abandonné ce bon
je vais avoir une mauvaise nuit
ces deux visages ensoleillé ce matin
énergisé monde et moi j'en 10h15 j'ai
fait faute d'absence a levé le drapeau
blanc de bonne heure et quart hier matin
parce qu'on dit c'est fini
[Rires]
non mais on dirait que c'était
exactement le même scénario mais en fait
c'est quand pékin veut sortir pendant
qu'on va le savoir lui qui gagne petit
mais je te l'élevage est pas il sort
quand la semaine prochaine
pile
as tu encore j'ai abandonné j'étais dans
ma chambre je dis que tu es ton show
complet ça va me faire monter le match
décalé côté bad dans ton show ouais non
mais je pense que tu as fait dessus non
bayer fait lens mamad à mesure j'ai plus
ou moins sur scène à cause de la coved
j'ai pu aussi dans mon parce que je
serais déjà une aide matérielle de mon
éventuel quatrième choc je suis passé
j'ai un gag de trump jeunesse' censure
boyd
[Rires]
mais je me suis auto show il ya une
blague samica dipietro une blague
politique qui bouge 26 blague politique
mais en fait c'est comme un gag que que
j'ai promise et un soir parce que en
fait pour moi tant côté que ceux qui
n'ont pas vu ce que j'ai comme un bout
que je dis c'est le superviseur de mon
show puis je dire garder l'oeil le blush
17h10 pays bout qui se fout complètement
tout ce qui se passe à sa droite
je l'appelais à mercredi quand j'ai dit
la blâmer jeux les jeux les pros visé ça
a tellement marché jeu balle va regarder
comment rajouté après tenue mais ça se
voulait pottas gag sur kadir le step et
sa poésie écrit comme ça c'est vraiment
arrivé de façon que tu sais quoi le
pourcentage des gars que tu fais
son approvisionnement en eau spot très
peu parce que moi j'ai le cac 1 j'arrive
sur scène avec une première ébauche de
texte pour un rodage
je sais les textes sur le bout des
doigts sauf que versus mon début de
carrière je suis un peu plus
je suis un peu plus dégagé donc ça fait
en sorte que quand il s'y passe des
trucs qui sont pas prévu je peux sortir
de mon personnage en début de carrière
je refuse que mon personnage
j'ai comme maintenant mais si charles de
mon personnage personnes vont y croire
quand je vaux rien embarqué dans le
personnage savoir décridibiliser mais
maintenant je dirais qu'il ait pas de
casse ont beaucoup aidés est d'ailleurs
que je me montre sur le jour que je suis
donc ça fait en sorte que dans mon
troisième chose justement battu le
regardais hier php regarder parce que
c'est plus moi mais non mais plus je
suis plus proche de qui je suis j'ai
poussé un sourire en coin
c'est comme si j'avais une auto-analyse
de mon personnage pendant que je que je
performe puis ça si je pense que c'est
le podcast permise ce dégagement l'os
cette aisance là et qui fait en sorte
que je pense que les gens m'aiment et me
fends non compris la convention de bon
son vécu qui raconte les débours pas si
ble ment vrai des boues possiblement
fictif mais on accepte de se prêter au
jeu puis on on trouve pas que c'est
nuisible qui passent de l'un à l'eau
mais je sais même pas pourquoi on parle
de tout parce que tu me demandais ce
qu'il ya de plus qu'avant en début de
carrière et on avait zéro même que mon
premier show s'il se passait quelque
chose dans sa halle si on l'évoqué même
pas la cus fois c'est un sale gosse mais
pauvre est quasiment sauvé j'exagère un
peu mais je me rappelle mon premier show
je faisais un choix victoriaville à
l'ancien cinéma puis il ya eu une panne
d'électricité balshaw mais statines
d'une panne d'éclairage parce que mon
micro fonctionne encore j'avais mon
micro casque fonctionner encore fait
faites-le je me suis mis à profit ses
j'ai pas le choix on voyait plus rien
fait que j'ai fait un genre de 15
minutes d'impro de bombay
est ce que c'est drôle quand même même
si on me voit pomme je consomme la ferme
au texte j'ai proposé un peu enfin
malgré des sorties mais il a du mal
après le show les spectateurs étaient
certains que sté écrit oh oui joachim et
susciter prévu la panne fait que
maintenant pour priver non mais pour
quatrième chose ça va être mon ami jo à
pain si c'est un jour sur joe bayda puis
au bout 400 jack black max après simple
et danois enfin si vous aussi ça j'ai
déduit que vous êtes les habits en sang
ouais ouais on est un couple enfin c'est
ça on est ravi ça se passe bien ça se
passe bien jusqu'à d'argent qui est ce
qu'un hack clip le dos à l'eau parce que
mon ancien coloc
est ce que toi le doute pas tant mais on
sent quand même le besoin de le clip et
ben je ressens le besoin de demander à
quelqu'un de médée qui palier c'est plus
pour les ménages sera intéressant
entrons là demain pour la santé de
l'action de récup et le dos mais je
trouvais ça amusant parce que lui 10-0
homophobe mais les contacts go sale
gosse un peu parce que moi ça me dérange
et roulera ça si je sais que l'hôtel
golf club tient plus at il dit était
comme un peu obligé d'accepter que je le
touche parce qu il y avait deux conclu
sa condition au dos et portant
l'épilation qui aiment le clippage était
plus propre et sèche le dos après chaque
douche et n'était pas dans la salle de
bains thermaux j'ai fini
amelia 56 ans c'était au 1 peu sèche
sèche semi reptilienne non mais on
n'agresse pas le fait qu'ils mangeaient
decideo des sourds il sait pourquoi je
surveille tous
et puis sa façon de ce qui s'est passé
dans sa façon de me dire c'était qu'il
fallait qu'il se soit en deux étapes un
peu sa vie comme pas un exfoliant mais
les gens de près crème puis après ça la
crème qui une touche de crème pour
coucher avec lui pour 10 telle ta vie ta
paix comme des maracas et tous ont ce
recul tient à sa couleur 7 9 à 16 hockey
non je m'ennuie beaucoup de mecs ainsi
comme système
des fois on se dit choquée des fois je
[Musique]
m'inquiète mais maintenant j'en ai pas
beaucoup et puis pige pour ça me dérange
tout le monde sait s'il bien garni je le
disais à mon sujet que l'on voit très
bien moi je raconte à part tout allait
bien mais dans le dos je n'ai pas de
talent mais des fois je fais quatre
bateaux de clip et un peu puis s'est
hâté j'arrête d'être un peu plus
pudiques pas raconter ça mais c'est sans
filtre pas d'imagés ont donc aucun fait
il ya dit je me tords sione pour essayer
de thé avec des mouvements de miroirs
c'est sûr que tu te rends paul bert à
peu près partout et une once en doublant
doux nom se quittent la région d'evra
logique comme les thons loti béton comme
ça c'est dur puis comme ça ça fait mal
fackeure préfère de sylvie stick arcade
plus loin jamais je n'ai pas que j'ai
pas que ce soit à gaz peut-être marie
pas qu'un prototype
je pensais qu est ce que je me disais
mais qui paie le dos mais est ce que tu
aurais besoin parfois un peu j'ai très
peu de poil à douma où il faut chaud et
on nous le
mais est-ce que tu serais prêt à y faire
si tu fais de la natation longtemps
imputé annotations on se rase
on sera au bik tout puis d'un
compétition importante c'est vraiment
fort qu'eux on est les gars quand le peu
comme des singes qui se mange le laisser
libre 12 mai mais ces cinq ans rasé le
dos à la purger coin ailleurs mais ouais
moi j'ai beaucoup de poids mais y en
avait dans l'équipe qui en avait
beaucoup le fait que mais il y avait des
demandes est juste un peu floue et j'ai
comme quelqu'un qui avait fait de la
natation qui avait dit que ce n'est pas
juste de l'esthétisme était aussi
aucunement de l'esthétisme 0 mais
comment je pense que ceux qui y croient
ils répondent friction niveau de l'eau
nouioui tout à fait ça n'est pas le
béton qui mombreux qui peut être oui
mais tu as besoin mes attentes et à
barbe
quand tu vois dans une piscine ne tombe
plus de 5,4 sortent de l'eau qui coule
encore pesé plus lourd mais ça c'est de
la résistance quand tu quand une banque
puis quand tu t'entraînes tu ta vie pour
des centièmes de secondes ça vaut
vraiment la comprends mais je pense
c'est quand même un peu une façon de se
dédouaner
on est à peu près cette réflexion là est
beaucoup plus exact pour mettons les
cyclistes qui sera gelée jan glent ma
réflexion et l accumulation la tienne
est plus exact pour les cyclistes que
pour l'émergence d'une majorité des
cyclistes qui se rasent les jambes ça
pas beaucoup d'impact sur
l'aérodynamisme surtout sim et un
cuissard hyper tacle assassin le poignet
en fait en fait peut-être une raison que
je pense pas mais c'est surtout que les
feelings après têtes rasées partout sur
le corps d'être complètement à doullens
plaida l'etna les anton l'ipd frotter
dans découverte l'un des plus beaux
films récents ya pas grand chose de plus
cool qu'à devenir de se raser les jambes
pitt se frotter dans des droits d'auteur
je veux faire encore des gens quelles
discussions mais non mais moi mettons
c'est arrivé j'ai eu un
électroencéphalogramme dans ces fameux g
électrocardiogramme il ya maintenant
deux ans parce que je joue à qui des
fois j'avais des gens de palpitations
puis je ne vais pas mon pas de son
vivant puis mon père était médecin
m'avait dit ben ça m'inquiète pas fait
peut-être des c'est peut-être des crises
de tachycardie anodine mais peu importe
à 15 août 1 1 et tours cardy mois puis a
fait que j'ai eu 1
mon mieux c'est un auteur pendant 24
heures avec roach est faux car ce
pistage en trois semaines avant que
maria jamaïque babel trois ont tout fait
pour moi je salue que j'ai galice pêche
je me dise pas avec un trou puis je
trouvais mon chess dégarni odieux
c'était comme parce que je suis zéro aux
tiges pour muscler qu'équipe au muscle
il n'y a pas de poil ça fait vraiment
chaud
tout y est pour beaucoup c'est un peu
attaqué et autres indiquent elles plus
que jamais à quel point tu es oui
absolument
non mais à quel point tu as tu le dit et
c'est important pardon sa pilosité
mais c'est plus l'habitude on voudrait
que là au début car j'ai eu mes premiers
poils de chat et comme après sa mort -
c'est sûr que ça n'allait pas moi je ne
suis pas moi parce qu'au début c'est
comme si je lis jamais je me suis mis
dans une pièce à part la fois qu'on me
l'imposé mais je me suis que ammann est
jetée corps va évidemment je pense que
ça me garde ni un peu de chance ça
m'était pas quelque chose auquel je
réfléchis aux cotisants gère les maisons
mais juste à bab et très bientôt y est
bien taillée taille et tout un prototype
avec un bâton il venu ici puis lui c'est
vraiment legault le plus soft comme
chose de sa pilosité que je rencontrais
dans ma vie ok il en a parlé plus
parfois piété comme telle et les firmes
axe est important d'habitants ye li
s'est acheté une joie de tondeuses à
poils de nez et associe sérieux en a
tâché de sourcil ouais mais this is ok
tu achètes au pharmaprix s'est fait
travailler sur six ben moi j'aurais dit
ralph a dit jacky languirand il faut
j'en ai un qui se rebelle qui fait oui
mais ça me prend un point quatre
secondes c'est le fait une fois par mois
ben là surprise surprise mais ce n est
pas quelque chose que j'ai jamais fait
ouattara sita l'a bien clean pour une
poignée bas j'en ai pas beaucoup le
j'imagine mais je me tiens c'est ce
métier comme ses salariés dans la
théorie mais moi j'ai jamais tout jamais
cherché de ma ville
mettez jamais un petit poêle rébarbatif
de sourcil mettons ou ici entre les deux
taux jamais eu un gregory charles pasqua
que j'ai c'est bon qu'il n'en mets moi
que ceci dit je peux de temps que moi
mais ton jeu je trouve que le rasage
comme les nageurs la natation - béton on
dirait que j'avais fait une job gabbana
son père paul là dessus dans un épisode
c'est que je marie miel julian ma fille
ma faute
salah stressait ddd des poils de go qui
repose trop de rues parce ça fait comme
jarre plus le poids les raser plus dur
si puis là je vous avais fait de la
mouche on met dans le bain à l'époque
cronenberg savait que jeff goldblum at
school bus la mouche à la mouche dulce
en fait c'est comme un certain god qui
fait des expériences pilotes
il veut vivre
transposition une formation non une
transpiration
c'est le fin non une voyant une
déréglementation téléportation 36
matches qu'on a vieilli sans défaut les
mots il faut c'est que j'ai mal dormi
mais ne faisaient pas mais en fait il
veut écrire une exportations et les
importations il comme dans un cubicule
puis il veut voir s'ils souhaitent ch
dans l'autre véhicule
sauf qu'au moment du switch doigt la
téléportation il y avait une moche
faction sa permutation nine blend et
avec une mouche bleue man né il ya comme
son son poil est super dru parce que
c'est de voir le match de moche ou des
poils de moosch taxe c'est programme des
images que moi plus d'assez le sens
l'histoire du cinéma
parce que on dirait qu'on sent que c'est
comme que du pus puisse le poil veut
sortir je m'exprimerai gens qui mangent
fait qu'il ya mandela le visage du 04
grâce à poudre pour de la france mais
bref si ce fait que je pense à raser ap
hirsch bonne idée parce que toutes les
écluses de la pelouse mais je ne sais
pas je pense que c'est un mythe le fait
c'est soit que le moment ça pousse ça
pique pileux sûr ça peut être ta main
mais je pense que c'est un mythe que
genre si tu trust voir venir avec plus
de poils ainsi proximité c'est un mythe
aussi ouais ouais d'affaires s'est tuée
par la mouche parce que moi je fais
toujours bien attention car je me rase
pour pas monter trop haut pour pas rendu
pour jouer loin et provoquer
mais ça arrive pas le mettais j'ai quand
même l'impression que quelqu'un mais
tant parce que j'ai hâte de me rappeler
des jobs de tous et chauffage et là
c'est pas mon premier choix numéro qu'un
petit bébé téléguidé je faisais comme si
je veux pratiquer pour être papa plus
qu'un jeu par les agents vie souvent de
trois et il y avait jean maintenant
jeudi kbc moureaux giraldi joulaud votre
souvenir barbu genre à un an et demi
mais bon j'ai quand même l'impression
j'ai pas trop le temps que je me rase
lefranc glace qu'il n'y a pas de poids
tant ce serait quand même fou de la
barbe de francs cfa à bab le chef
voltige ses besoins de 12 fois mais
j'allais acheter sa petite machine à
poils de nez est en sursis c'est quand
même autre pharmacie me dit tu vois le
s'agissait d'autoriser cia batterie qui
tacle à tulle tourne évidemment
d'emmener tout est pas là disparaissent
lors de ce même site en bout sur le bout
s'était passé le sourcil peut-on sur
site vieille comme tout égard c'est le
fun mais c'est comme ça ça se met tant
pour le sourcil pph cette année mais je
tiens à préciser comme avec les peurs à
cheveux yop pour la la tondeuse à
sourcilleux sur grade faire en sorte
justement que soient bien il ya une
seule longueur enfin fonctions à l'aise
avec sept longueurs de sourcil leur
gueule que tu choisis mais oui mais
l'autre fois sur longtemps je les fais
ça j'arrête d'y amener tout mon arsenal
mais l'odeur est la question la question
en fait c'était c'était plus largement
mais tant qu'on recule un peu plus ma
chronique on pense à l'utilité des poils
tant pis les poils de nez de ce que jean
comprenait la raison pour laquelle les
polonais étaient restés peut servir de
filtre naturel alors qu'était inspire
dans ton nez
techcite une rose au complet que ça fait
mais je pense que c'est qu'aucun paul
d'année depuis de d'ordre du j'entends
que vous avez beaucoup de dix mètres se
faire fabriquer de dorothée da costa
fait pour vrai je passe ça aucun sens
que tu perdes l'europe à ce que tu te
rases totalement les poils d'année
scolaire atteint anatomiques
mais les particules les particules qui
restent pris dans ton pas le but
on est trop dans la vase pourquoi mais
je pense qu'avec qui a compté aussi que
que ça aide
si on se mouche parce que manif au
catapulté quelques quelques résidus
paul fin ça fait un frein ça fait un
frein quand même ou sinon recrues
d'après bob le chef ces jeunes qui
gouttelettes le plus mal
lakovic cette écoute la nasa mais en
même temps si ça c'est l'utilité de
poils de nez c'est quoi le tilter de
poils de poche m'attend là dessus je
tâche et non pas très garni c'est bien
chez ge comptage est toujours resté un
peu dégueulasse était garnie mais ils
sont bien équipés
bapaume et b mais très peu ok ce qu'elle
automoteurs j'en avais un débat sur de
la mana qu'on s'en occupe et des baux un
nom dans notre intimité le gt yohann
thuram m soit ici ou là mais quels
outils utiliser jack les prêts cheveux
gris bh mais sur le sac sur le sac de
couilles à eau aimé jacquet peu très
doux je le pense pas mais parce que la
fois j'ai essayé ça ça fait mal à part
nous promettait le scrotum très fragile
je lisais sur ton coeur sur internet
c'est ce qu'on m'apprenne parce que
c'est oui c'est pas mal ce qui traîne
ces élections les scrutins fragile deux
ans pour ceux des questions mais bref
moi j'utilise le rasoir de l'alhambra
puis moi c'est un génie maudit ce talent
je m'appelais pascal a été passé non non
non non que ses péages
ça me fait froid dans le dos le pied en
début de carrière de rasage et
j'essayais adam piste et c'était il
fallait que je vais mettre des 10 des
kleenex l'avouer c'est ça allait quand
même moi j'imagine sur mon sac
nancy nice et j'ai envie de mourir
ah ouais moi c'est toi ce qui me
l'afrique in glass le 5 un peu comme
tout ça de glacer le sang c'est vraiment
spécifique mais quand du carton l'hiver
il est un redoux fait que le ca commence
à fond dans la masse marais refroidi
google ils font comment un pic avec moi
l'image que j'ai qui met cap jallet la
10e un frisson c'est ce que tu dis là
des liens glace on tombe à pointe d'un
sur ton grand pic saint jean d'août vous
c'est comme si c'est ce qu'ils y plante
comme fournier comme ça ferait un espèce
de comme des balais ou des licols tout
le site
tous se stabilise de remplir et cela a
ses bons pourquoi ce qui classe le sens
et le sait le sont ceux qui tombent je
comprends que ça peut glacer le sang et
puis ça apparaît comme dangereux mais
toi ski de glace le sang c'est qu'un
glaçon ne cache pas rentrer dans ton
crâne puis saas comme donc c'est là
c'est le fils de pénétration eglingen
selon iran s'est dit qu'il rentrait
qu'une belle vélocité pour faire le
plein et pour ceux qui cassent et stable
le film en est assez stable
je te dirais que c'est sur sa glace le
sang ouais mais c'est comme da fin qui
fait grincer des dents des façons en
défaut il disait gratte sur un tableau
de la table au mois c'est cette image là
toujours aussi chargé de la session
selafa l'apf lagarde tandis que c'est
sûr que la deuxième c'est une déception
par rapport à ce qu'est ce qui me glace
le sang je trouve pas le sens bien je
vous le dirais pour ma part
la bad au moulin mais je sais pas ce que
je pensais de la ram dessert quelque
chose comme imaginer ma tondeuse nasal
qui qui lors du nettoyage n'a plus de
patrie c'est pas un très bon impôt de ma
faute ce projet solidarité moi aussi
j'étais ça va mais donc on s'éloigne un
petit peu du poil puis de la pilosité le
puits de l'entretien physique
dommage d'être quand une bonne demi
heure
tu parlais tantôt de décommander fois
maintenant taxer plus de sortir de ton
personnage mais ton personnage es-tu
vraiment si loin de toi c'est parce que
mettons telle offre clairement tu
imagines tu es pas dans ton personnage
en ce moment tu étais juste ou
affections de réponse ton cerveau
fonctionne un petit peu la même que
comme ton personnage semble fonctionner
l'ue doit exact en fait je dirais que le
jeu de plus en plus loin de mon
personnage initial mais je dirais que la
grosse différence souvent qu'un jeu faut
que je lui explique ce que je dis que la
grosse différence avec mon personnage
c'est que moi je le sais que didier
aussi l'huile cpo battant - qu'est fac
c'est comme si je me servais de lui pour
dire des âneries mais moi je le sais que
ça n'a aucun sens mais lui sur scène son
attitude c'est ça a le mérite d'être
racontée ce intéressant c'est un peu
comme mon numéro du restaurant début de
carrière c'est moi le sexe a aucun
incident sans s'expliquer le rouge un
restaurant mais lui c'est pour affirmer
non je pense intéressant
je pense que je vais apporter je vais
apporter de l'éducation jean taxicom t
mais c'est quand même moi qui crise qui
disent que le niveau d'ironie moi je
dirais que c'est que moi je suis
beaucoup plus conscients de l'ironie est
pour lui
puis jusqu'à demain ben ironique dans
vie c'est comme ma façon pour moi de
d'alléger la ville qui peut être parfois
lourdes pour tout le monde donc pour moi
l'ironie c'est comme le second degré
c'est comme ma façon un peu d'évacuer
fait je dirais que le mot lui c'est un
peu mon pantin pour évacuer une forme
d'ironie une excuse je trouve que dans
l'umoa dont il comme un peu une façon
d'ironiser l'arl dans d'ironiser leur
kyelu mots puis lire nice pour moi c'est
une bonne façon de ne pas de poste
prendre au sérieux
puis mon personnage servi de boucliers
si c'est pas le sait comme une analyse
que j'avais fait part à primer c'est
comme calculé de jeu
je m'en vais jouer avec le vide sur
scène philosophiquement 0 mais peut-être
qu'inconsciemment il mon ironie mon
second degré de la vie belle le
transposer sur scène ça ne me fait du
bien le d'un sens que bon on fait tout
ça un peu pour 50 et humoriste du jeu
moi je voulais pas être connu dans ma
vie mais je voulais faire des affaires
que j'aime et puis je suis au début
comme j'ai déjà expliqué dans d'autres
pas tiens à m'excuser et je voulais
écrire puis je me suis rendu compte que
l'école de l'humour quand ils m'ont dit
ben on monte on s'intéresse à mon sais
pas qui tu peux donner ces textes là
donc ils m'ont peut se découper
l'intérieur pour le
que ce soit moi qui mets mais je pense
quand même que moi c'est sûr je pourrais
porter la question somme toute somme
toute est grosso modo cela devant vous
totalement aucunement une facette de moi
qui se dit bon faut que je sois un peu
plus à eaunes parce que c'est un pas de
casse ou timo quand je faisais pas de
cash je suis moi à puisieux des boots
plates deal with my shit mais au début
ma tante avait su ce que personnage suis
et je veux être tout le temps personnage
que plus je le suis toujours de rendre
flous espèce de ligne entre le réel il
était un peu comme andy kaufman frais le
titre des moins bonnes questions
j'aimais beaucoup effectivement t on à
vendre pas de question de parler de
madeco se voit c'est seulement quand
même le deuxième niveau dans ta vie
aussi loin mais c'est comme si comme
étant comme je l'expliquais souvent sur
la russe une vraie passion ouais ça pour
sans réel intérêt que je capote sur show
là mais je le sais que la déco c'est une
grosse connerie c'est dans ce sens que
je les fait avec sourire puis je trouve
ça beau puis ça fait en sorte que je
baigne dans l'univers que j'aime mais je
le sais bien que ce qui arrive chez nous
avec what the shit en six courses ça me
faisait recam et en amont à sienna
partie la concierge est rentré ses
percées reconnaissez plus ou moins bon
de penser qu'à rentrer dans une maison
de 2 3 ou parce que des filles aussi
mais en fait c'est parce que j'ai
souvent que j'aime bien les les joueurs
un peu mais cherchons le maire joseph
active + 10' des femmes et sébastien
d'astous 8 le droit mais c'est un peu
flou des collègues qui étaient là pour
montrer à tout le monde mais c'est ça le
hic est que même la concierge qui
t'arrive tu nous tiens à regarder est
venu pour une réparation auprès valu un
truc de plomberie pis elle ne faisait
que ses mémoires en radio mais qu'est ce
qu'il va faire
mais mais ça ça impossible de louer mais
là ça me fait rire quand même pis j'aime
le fait qu'en début de carrière je pense
qu'il ait pas de casse ont un peu fait
en sorte que les gens savent plus que je
conscient que si ridicule mais j'aimais
sûr que le monde savent pas trop à quai
il ya un flou quand même autour de toi
le loyer sérieux et eu aussi des accès
c'est souvent dit souvent que les gens
comparent avec parle de andré sauvé
françois bellefeuille ou petits sont
vraiment plus populaire que moi ces deux
humoristes le puis moi je pense que ce
qui explique qu'ils sont plus populaires
c'est qu'ils sont des fous claire mouche
comme un fou donc là parce que l'autre
c'est souvent ils parlent de façon
extravagante qui ont un look extravagant
il parle beaucoup de leurs propres folle
dix mois tandis que moi j'en parle pas
vraiment jaloux star de labé normal puis
j'ai pas ne jugez pas une attitude de
sign extravertie donc je comme pas clair
si ça que j'aime en même temps j'aime
les faits que mon besoin de le cerner
mais ce qui me concerne il me semble
complètement avions compris second degré
mais je donne - les clés mais je n'étais
pas calculer mais ça me déplaît pas de
pas trop de françois bellefeuille tous à
propos de plus clair la différence entre
le goût et le personnel jacques cccc ça
saute aux yeux en entrevue tu le vois de
suite les y ai jamais c'est françois
davy sardou lits sont à poser souriante
sur cinq les user bronches après tout
qui dit il tout le moins de moindre
petite chose donc ses sorties c'est pire
andré sauvé il parle beaucoup de saint
evroult ge et les cheveux ébouriffés
vieillit très des en direct tout seul
plus forme plus sain tout tandis que moi
c'est comme un ouais mais je pense que
je pense que dans mon troisième chose
c'était plus clair
vu que je faisais des des blagues ou des
numéros un peu plus collés sur ce que
j'avais vécu mais je pense quand même
que depuis le début de ma carrière là
peut-être que mon show le plus
accessible celui là mais il ya bien des
gens peut-être tu es mon premier show je
pense j'ai vendu 115 mille billets mais
je chantais quand même que mes fans
tripes et des curieux sont venus qui dit
curieux qui ont entrepris mais d'autres
quitter comme où suis-je noires sont
revenues au deuxième puis ça fait un
genre de tri skis et ski et ski et ben
correct en fait moi je comprends ses
défauts en tant qu'etat parler de
quelqu'un je vois les bronches et
intrigue il t'arrive le cross je
comprends absolument pas sa proposition
qui s'est pas fait moi je me rappelle
puis le je vais pas te veux pas te
vieillir plus que plus que tu que tu les
lots conforme et quinquin quand je me
rappelle d'avoir vu pour la première
fois j'étais quand même jeune je me
rappelle ma dit what the fuck moi
c'était le premier contact que j'avais
je devrais je pas un érudit du mot je
tripais pas sûr sur les lits système
d'apam eric mc avoy l'apix et puis je
m'appelle me dis qu'est ce que c'est que
je dis ce que je viens de voir
d'entendre là je m'appelle avoir trouvé
ça extrêmement drôle mais c'était mon
premier contact avec de l'humour champ
gauche comme seul lui comme d'un espèce
de personnages qui qui pince sans rire
un peu 10 à faire complètement rend-on
je me rappelle ma dit comme à ses hôtes
et d'avoir compris ce soit suite mais en
fait tu te tais était haute
je suis donc
c'est sous ces noms à faire 500 dumas
qui me quand même à moi mais qui
semblent immenses toi aussi tu es haute
de comprendre mon humour jamais on zappe
je comprenais des gîtes ou non mais
c'est parce que amende il y avait
comment il s'appelle catherine perrin à
la radio qui avait analysé mon style
d'humour est allé voir apprendre à
s'aimer
le mot dernier puis je trouve que c'est
une critique je vois mal à recréer ce
qu'elle dit mais a envoyé sa commune
comme une graine dans le cerveau de
quelqu'un qui pigent les deux guerriers
a dit gentiment pour le comprendre
de la graine au dessus de paul savait
qu'en disant ouvrir les écluses de
ménaka mourir elle est prononcée navire
foule vous n'êtes pas armé qui s'était
comme tu dis tu étais pas un geek du
monde à ses serments métaux compris le
second degré où l'étrangeté de leur
acheter plus que le second degré au
moment alors que j'avais 15 ans je suis
tombé mais ça c'est quand même traduit
par de tels que ryu est tout à fait mais
il y en a que ça va être plus qui sont
fâchés
les gens quittent encore saute en début
de carrière et quand les gens savaient
pas trop pourquoi la personne à côté
crampes et moi je doute de fax à
l'effort c'est qu'est-ce que comme
indiqué ce que je comprends pas mais il
faut justement poc
il faut des fois je dis aux femmes en
m'écoutant faut mettre son son cerveau
aaron ou complètement très dansant ce
que faut pas trop se poser de questions
de ce qui veut dire aussi courte qu'ici
c'est quoi son point il ya des potes
c'est juste ça peut être complètement
donne aux gens une image tiki surprenant
tout ça n'est pas un message caché entre
les lignes
pas vraiment jetons chaud à l'envers ça
dit on et les enfants de satin là les
shows de danse si c'est un gars que je
baisse mon ami john hancock et wayne on
sait ça j'ai même que sauvage m j'ai
fait ce une couple de fois dans mes
shows ironisé l'humour un message parce
que des fois les gens souvent il y avait
un moment on dit du marais s'apprend pas
à ces positions puis moi ça ça mérite et
comme revendication des gens qui il faut
qu'il faut que les humoristes catane
tribune votants serve comme 16 route
c'est pourquoi ces sèche
chaque personne reçoit l'heure combien
envie de le recevoir leurs savoirs de le
consommer moi je j'aime ce côté des
défunts mou de l'art que je vu qu'on est
tous des éponges dans la vie je
l'absorbent comme comme je l'aï souvent
fonction de mes valeurs en fonction de
qui je suis en fonction de qu'est-ce que
j'aimerais que ça cesse a dit pour moi
si c'était moitié
je suis à paris de deux films le bout
des autres qui mon film préféré
tous les temps qui est un film que en
fait j'aime pas quand le message que
l'artiste veut dire peu importe la forme
d'art caillé trop et niort files pour
moi ya pas de subtilité puis ça me plaît
moins j'aime que s'esquisse et la toile
de fond qui s'en dégage
mais on ne l'écrit pas noir sur blanc le
sait c'est comme on aime divertit mais
la vibe la vague que j'en reçois ces
sautes comme le goût des autres
la toile de fond du film c'est parfois
une comédie dramatique avec des châssis
croisade plusieurs personnes qui sont
d'horizons différents mais la toile de
fond c'est parfois on ont dix cartes des
gens trop rapidement parce qu'ils ont
des goûts vraiment différent nous et ça
fait en sorte que peut-être que cette
personne là pour nous à pors apporter
plus mais on ne donne pas la chance
parce que mettons
on apprend qu ils tripent sur moi même
j'ai ces réflexions parfois puis ce film
le mot comme ça que je sais c'est pas
mon film préféré pour ces raisons là
c'est très drôle et touchant c'est super
bien écrit mais j'adore le message une
source le message qu'on entend pas assez
c'est vrai que des fois on a tendance à
catégoriser du monde trop rapidement
alors qu'on devrait pas faire ça parce
que si on me donne un peu plus une
chance mais dont on se ramasse dans une
pièce on se fait imposer pendant une
semaine avec une personne qui vraiment
loin de nous pendant qu'ils apprennent
semaine soit faire comme flamands j'ai
jugé trop vite c'est une belle semaine
on a appris à la fouille un peu plus
loin voir tes sens il dit qu'est ce que
l'on peut apporter à l'autre mais
défense donne même pas cette chance
non ce physique at il dit dans le fond
de cette auscultation dingue une telle
expansion adopté dit madeleine chancy
peut-être pas juste un gars qui a la
passion du rugby acteurs exemple des
jeux via l'atelier des fois tu peux
aussi te rends compte maintenant tu met
quelqu'un dans une maison vingt quatre
heures pendant 24 heures en une semaine
ça se peut te rends compte aussi que
finalement tu as vraiment rien en commun
que cette personne là puis ici pas
capable de rester avec la russie mais il
ya tragique s'est fait quand tu as dit
que tu as laissé la chance te lécher la
chance le yu ti dans ce sens il se dit
qu'au petit secret se défend mais sa
cause de tuer une personne comme ça ça
empêche pas que que les choses sont
populistes se finit de façon ingénieuse
puis c'est des fois il découpe qui se
laisse après 15 ans puis il reste des
meilleurs amis il faut combien on a vécu
ce qu'on avait à vide point de vue un
mot l'oeil à quelque chose d'autre qui
se place puis c'est rien de signé perdu
ce les deux personnes le la finalité
paul et le parcours au complet
exact entend retirer quelque chose quand
même mais si je pense qu humainement
beaucoup de personnes peuvent nous
apporter quelque chose mais souvent la
vie c'est ridicule à autre chose ou se
séparent police en amour mais même en
amitié ou dans des des peut-être que des
fois les
les ce qui pourrait être ton meilleur
ami ou ta blonde mais ce ne sera jamais
parce que tu le trier trop vite comme
aussi des fois je suis un peu comme un
parallèle qui est bizarre le mais lens à
ce qu' il ya un côté berne de ma vie
puis peut-être celle là à ce moment dit
guttenberg si le gars le plus vite au
monde
mais peut-être qu'elle aime le plus vite
au monde je sais pas moi c'est même
payer juste chef est développée ça y est
j'ai jamais dis vous l'essayez c'est
alexander popov qui est un agent russe
qui était un des meilleurs sprinteurs au
monde lui disait sprint à lui disait d
alexander popov et en a probablement à
chaque coin de rue c'est juste qu'ils
auront jamais nager mais c'est
totalement d'accord avec ses enfants et
ses à-côtés berhane damas identifié nos
champs de compétences savoir qu'on est
bon et d'hommes y est peut-être ce
serait peut-être un haltérophile
exceptionnel mais ils le gèrent essayer
non medidas à ce que quelque chose de
juste à côté au rang de mela la vie sur
ce vraiment ça me fascine parce que j'ai
débordé et peut-être pas aux amitiés
contrit où se met en fête
en fait ce qu'il allait dire c'est que
j'ai l'impression que dans la société
auquel on vient en ce moment qui est
ultra divisé ça accentue encore plus
cette
ce tri rapide le trop que ce soit juste
mettant mettons qu'on regarde en ce
moment parce que c'est l'actualité aux
etats-unis le dessus tête un démocrate
tu rencontres un républicain c'est fini
tu y es tu t'engages pas la conversation
en ce moment sur un gros problème de
division sur nous mêmes ici sur plein de
sujets laitiers
est-ce que ce soit sur les masques
tombent qui est qui et qui est contre le
port du masque obligatoire si quelqu'un
qu'ils les pauvres est ce que c'est
vraiment la seule balle sur laquelle
baser votre et votre
niveau de compatibilité si vous avez
plein d'intérêt commun qui sont pas
seuls mais souvent aussi pense qu'en
plus à la des réseaux sociaux le soin
est du monde quittait son veau souvent
sa maman que j'ai fait un peu de ménage
sur facebook le monde y voit des statuts
d'idéologie ou de réflexions qui sont
pas les leurs ils font comme moi j'en
est ce un métier on dirait que sur les
réseaux sociaux je peux comprendre un
peu plus c'est maintenant tu sais que
c'est quelqu'un qui voit jamais où
qu'ils habitent super loin de ce fait
comme j'ai pas envie de nous faire
alourdi par quelque chose qui est
quotidien je table sur l'évolution
annexe encaissements est temps qu'ils
rentrent dans un trou du lapin noir mais
je pense quand même ses commettants
républicain versus démocrate
je pense qu'il y en a des plus nuancée
qui peuvent se parler
si je j'aimais beaucoup les missions de
west wing une émission sur un
gouvernement démocrate martin sheen qui
était le président
mais qui a que j'étais vraiment bien
fait parce que c'était pas un show de
propagande de gauche c'était très tout
était bien nuancé des fois l'apport
républicain la réflexion républicaine
était entendue parce qu'ils avaient des
personnages forts de l'opposition qui
souvent des fois faisait faire
comprendre c'est quoi la vision il le
pourquoi humainement de cette vision là
c'était vraiment intéressant
je trouve c'est un show que tout le
monde c'est vraiment premier américain
mais c'est un show qui diffusait du bien
écouter parce que c'était pas du konia
ge sur cloud cloud d'un bord ou de
loaded et oui au gouvernement démocrate
mais la vision républicaine qui peut
parfois être nuancée même humaines
étaient aussi entendus je trouve ça
vraiment bien fait parce que j'ose
croire qu'il ya quand même
il y en a des idées des polarisé fou qui
doivent se chicaner factor a été je veux
tu vois pas les choses comme moi je veux
rien savoir de toi mais j'imagine
j'espère qu'il ya un an note qui
réussissent à se parler doucement phare
a lancé diane il ya de quoi de beau à
une conversation qu'ils pensaient du
temple
avec quelqu'un qui est vraiment
différent touati président d'accepter
outils de donner la chance au monde si
mettons ça fait maintenant deux ans que
l'on fait les podcasts ya plein de monde
que j'ai rencontrés que j'ai une
discussion pendant deux heures que
j'aurais jamais eu dans ville sinon ça
m'a porté de compte c'est toutes ces
personnes le ti en eux qui en a qui
seraient mes amis d'autres je me dit il
c'était vraiment un bon moment qu'on n'a
pas souhaité y mettons 6 à mai mais
c'est cool paraît utile de donner
justement un tassement de la pythie
mettant toute idée pht mettons au sud
des états-unis l'australie mais ton
début mars justement confinement au sud
des états unis cpie le monde la baule
seulement le plus fine c'est le monde
qui voter républicain le au sud et le
tennis et le monde les plus fins le plus
accueillant le propos lit le plus tout
n'était pas politique à cazaux mais sur
plein de points c'est du critt monde le
mot exact comme ceux dits doux alors on
est cette perception le vient de blanc
hétérosexuel et catholiques des
états-unis py tête un noir homosexuels
ça se pourrait que soient moins bien
reçus ces maisons là que nous
effectivement mais c'est sûr que trump
aussi à être être poste à des fêtes des
associations péjorative négative envers
les républicains avec son côté lahoud
sont massés s'intitule l'impression que
tout le monde doit agir de cette façon
là alors que c'est vraiment pas le cas
mais lui c'est comme le plus gros porte
étendard de l'histoire à tout cas
actuellement le pour les républicains
puis bin
[Musique]
singapour est la raison pour laquelle je
suis aussi émotionnellement investi dans
les élections américaines cette année
c'est parce que je mets ça pourrait être
un président républicain gens n'auraient
rien à crisser les tirs les allégeances
politiques qui au final tout s'est
défendue mais c'est vraiment pour la
personne qui s'appelle jacob bière qui
était vraiment intéressant à écouter les
extraits
c'est beaucoup à réfléchir sur trois
autres hommes s'en est pas mal de
conneries je suis là bas ce qui est ce
qui est ce qui est flagrant c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu un désaveu massif
comment ça va finir mais ça peut-être
grenon et dépendamment si si si ben
laden est fini par se squeeze bosum
avons des contestations celle qu on veut
savoir quand le podcast sortir sauf que
une flagrante chose lagarde c'est qu'ils
sont pas des aveux exercice ouverture
les mêmes qui peut-être solidifier des
tablettes graphiques la plaine plagiat
mais ne marche plus grande que qu'en
2016 ce qui est quand même
j'ai amené symboliser raphaël jacques
politi c'est vraiment un grand fan de la
faim jacob moore est j'ai trouvé
incroyable sa gueule ebay avait déjà
tendu pliage léger j comme écrit sur
tout et tout d'ailleurs pour toi j'ai vu
que cela change il répondu jetez pas sur
twitter mais je l'écoutais interdite ap
j'avoue je tombais sur lui juste et
comme ce match il y est parti on dirait
que j'ai dit dans mon tweet là la
politique j'aime cafard depuis lui
rendait sa - cafards dans lorsque il
était tellement passionné puis connaît
tellement son sujet puis ils verbalisent
tellement bien pire comme le genre de
disque au débat vous quelle famille pis
on dirait qu'ils oui coque mais je
trouve pas car elles se prennent au
sérieux car c'est comme un dosage
parfait que quelques moments qui est
mort on dirait qu'ils s'étaient comme un
petit guide 0 cartoon mais on dirait que
je les coupe une forme de divertissement
de caisse qui va dire parce qu'ils sont
sujets tellement maîtrisé que je te
colle pas à ses élèves le perche à tous
les autres par les jeter comme cela
[Rires]
patrice quoi ici il est il il contrôle
un peu long
c'était souvent comme le je vous en
laisse un peu les ij à buy de will
sûrement content de vous revoir en plus
j'ai pas très loin qui on enchaîne en
chignon famille way continue avec un psy
beef
c'est comme si je sais pas trop ce total
british analyse trop mais j'ai la
passion qui est patrice selon ce texte
immelt on a parlé ya un gars dans
syriana et redis je t'aime api batterie
soit six titres aux billets trop sacoche
partout en même temps c'est quand même
cinq ans devant lui il ya ces six
panélistes le monde la régie qui parle
puis on voudrait qu'ils regardent jamais
personne l'été ses yeux son camp david
en train de compiler vrai aussi que j'ai
géré un plateau de même pendant aussi
longtemps son attaque terrible vraiment
dans mes pauvres et moins mais
effectivement tu as raison que c'était
comme si patrice sablé pas toujours dans
le moment mais c'était comme si il
pensait toujours à qui vous demandez à
manger il se fait sûrement comme tu dis
garage plein de trucs dans les oreilles
des fouilles tks qu'on est oui puis
c'est sûr mais c'est quand même possible
de prendre le tas comme aujourd'hui à
sans filtre on
on prend le temps de jaser et on
pourrait faire peut-être une pause de 5
on fait juste de faire un petit moment
de relaxation je pense pour une fois
même tracé station ça semblait pressé
yepes est-ce que vous endormir parce que
j'ai des voix très feutrée le
réalisateur
nicole on voit il parle de jours est ce
que tu peux feutrée davantage ma voix
s'il vous plaît je vais j'ai essayé ce
jeu va voir sur le flanc droit mais 10e
et didier bès le hameau de la basse ada
150 hertz mousson nicole manipule ta
console avec douceur effervescence
nicosie web comme enfin le maîtrise at
il eu mondial de wever me nicole se fait
aider par son stagiaire
nicole est complètement largué soit fait
je décrivais par tous canadiens
son look est alors pacioretty qui est
revenu du canada a pas de gériatrie même
plus alors pacioretty qui fougueusement
se dirigent vers la zone à six faces
inconciliables la côte est quand même
c'est donc à l'intérieur écrit cela
peut-être qu'à ses parents tout le monde
a su rien tôt on dirait qu'il nageait
stadium bonjour nicholl nicholl dont
l'âge tu as pris de ton stagiaires j'ai
absolument tout appui grand-mère de la
river ben tu as tout à prix tu as fait à
liège en haut tu as tu as tout dit rita
briques t'as liaison doit être entre le
tout ils n'ont après un espace et tout
appris que haidar d'un crétin je ne
maîtrise même pas la langue française
s'il te plaît l'école redressement m
mois nicole m
mais oui je reconnais ma citation la
méditation guidée mai puis pourquoi
nicole décidé de faire nicole stott
crochemore nicole 6,6 son pire épisode
wii c'est à ce moment il vit pour lui
c'était comme sur l'addition pour avoir
une grosse guide télé publique retard
est le chef sait même pas quand mais des
vols programmés au calme et rouge puis
si il sait qu'il échappe
non en fait les méditations et et j'en
ai juste fait cinq genres et après 5
pour parce que parce que ces derniers
jours il ya plus court après non en fait
c'est que je t'attaque ans testé le
promis confinement piste un projet qui
m'avait toujours trotté dans la tête de
faire des méditation guidée parodique
l'humoristique puis l'acheter comme
barben insulta d'essayer passe chez un
ami qui est capable de faire de la
musique et du montage de l'audio donc
je faisais des j'avais comme un micro de
qualité puis j'enregistrais des trucs un
peu improvisé le premier épisode c'était
clairement que je vois improvisé en 25
minutes de niaiseries tout à briser le
premier épisode c'est tout d'impôts un
métier des fois même temps j'aime une
idée de jeu l'arrêt seyait je reprenais
le mais grosso modo c'était j'ai fini
par sept et six minutes je pense que ça
devait durer 21 mai mais je trouvais ça
comme plus j'avais l'impression que
j'allais plus vivre le moment si
j'essayais de les pros visite de croire
à mon personnes âgées cas puis fait
qu'après premier épisode je me suis dit
ok ben je vous rejoins en faveur d'eau
gelée fini par en faire 5-5 il ya peu
près jean 95 minutes de relaxation cuvée
j'aurais pu continuer mais j'avais
l'impression le premier épisode
beaucoup le voient pas ça c'est devenu
un peu plus méchant dire et où souvent
c'est ce qui arrive à être les premiers
épisodes sont comme très écouté ça fait
cinq ans devait recevoir aussi philippe
c'est des épisodes les vos bottes mais
après ça on dirait que le monde franck
et puis là il résulte est encore bon
sauf que je me dis bon vélo il de 40 95
minutes
c'est quand même pas mal de travail bien
je ne voulais pas partir de pâte riom où
tu voulais que ce soit gratuit pour tout
le monde mais moi j'avais c'est quand
même pas mal d'à après ça a choisi des
trucs au montage et que mon ami puis bon
ami fait face la muse et d'anti cgt
comme déficitaire dans le projet mais
c'est correct j'avais j'avais le goût de
le femme et faire 15 20 épisodes ont été
déficitaires à chaque fois bello et
j'aurais peut-être pu partir dans un
truc pour le rémunérer mitigé intentions
sûrement d'en faire d'autres
un jour le site de geler comme les cds
car tu es seule défaite 5 buts comme bon
ben ça existe en soi le sait ce qu'elle
veut passer une heure et demie et c'est
de ça dont même les cas pas les plus
beaux compliments que j'avais puis on
avait beaucoup d'un commentaire sur
youtube ou du monde qui m'écrivait pimms
est
je l'écouté je riais je me suis endormi
fait que les reptiles la main parce que
parce que je pense l'ambiance sonore de
ma voix la musique que mon ami a fait le
traitement il y avait quelque chose de
qui pouvait aller au sommet c'est pas
une
les parties pigeard je me suis ni trop
premières minutes après c'est son droit
je pense que moyen de faire que ça
fonctionne ça peut fonctionner pauvre fx
je pense ce qui m'amuse encore plus
c'est que le fait le monde ça servait
vraiment les mêmes accords du monde qui
me disait que j'étais encore des
épisodes en béton c'est à la fois que
madoff c'est la prochaine étape c'est de
partir du pôle web c'est ce qui joue
tout le temps que le ph on est le rendez
dans le concerne est en bonne place est
ce que tu te sens un nom de suggérer
pour notre entreprise ont tous tes potes
d'ascq use de sa fin oui elle a été
exclue pas de nom parfait c'est mieux
que j'ai trouvé je pas très bon mais
proviseur si on changeait pas le punch
comique moi je le sais tu que tous les
trucs le groupe 2 le porte parole ça
saoule go de données climatiques il a
indiqué mme way c'est ça mais ce serait
en fait le logo ce serait sa fin ok
c'est pas le plus détendu il peur qik
kiprop propose des tarés trimbach que
j'appellerais comme ça qu'un sport c'est
un bon avocat dia pareil succès
daguestan un bon on tue pour être dans
notre business six heures pour l'instant
t comme de gauche suippes au salon en
obtenir
il est bon au niveau là qui sait qui tu
es le boulet ce que j'ai encore plus une
nuisance chemical ou moins une nuisance
mettant simplement toi s'ils avaient
chacun vont faire nicole geren douzaine
de femmes totalisé si on devait les 46
nicole mène par deux femmes mais il
n'est pas de casser peaufine hippie ça
va plus on connaît les débats se fassent
au moins mon nico ils sont rasés à 0
c'est ce kindle j'étais passé et c'est
bien velu bien moi j'en prends soin
quand même oui
son benjamin adventure 2 parce que tu
ailles date fixée lors de tests
exactement les loges je me suis au grade
dont deux vitesses
c'est comme ça que ça doit marcher selon
moi c'est quoi le projet thd f
j'aimerais c'est que ça devienne le
podcast où il ya le plus intervenu ces
années de ce bar de damas proches mois
plus tard parce qu on y voit un compte
twitter
non j'ai pas de compte twitter en fait
je pense que oui mais
ça doit faire comme si six ans je pense
que je parle il c'est quoi ton seul
tweet m'attend je suis pas tweeté je
pense que je pense pas je suis pro maman
juste aller là dessus juste pour voir
c'est quoi
28 86 une mauvaise blague opération qui
m'écrivent sont surtout été le même
temps un troll ou qu'un pas puis des
fois j'ai du temps d'aller voir leur
historique de twic pied ce qui me ferait
des fois c'est mettons au début je veux
que les gens comprennent pas tout à fait
où c&a pas exactement comment ça marche
mais on me tonti m'écrivent récit mais
j'y vais à moi ça vaut mais des fois
j'en regarde dans leur histoire et là je
serai pas là en tant que ça sur twitter
via personnes qui les suit puis ont
marqué bonjour twitter personnes
souhaitant le voir j'ai pas de réaction
ne s'est pas d'aborder le monde se
rapprochent le savent pas mais on dirait
que ça me donne des missions possibles
barça les voir aller voir l'historique
des trois puits se sait sur toutes les
plateformes
c'est toujours bon ben c'est toujours
une bonne idée bah oui monsieur sa
relaxe par rapport à qui vient
d'attaquer personnellement de tirer
dessus pour les cas c'est à moi j'en ai
eu le génie
ouais ouais mais c'est 9 août indique un
témoin j'ai fait occupation 2 tu le sais
sûrement
puis quand je sortais de là j'ai eu une
période où est ce que mes tt et mes
enfants j'ai pas regardé
mais il ya quand même du monde qui tempo
de cette pipe l'ue se devait de plus
masculin ouais majoritairement masculin
sa fille est déjà jugée jalousie ou le
fait que
que je joue beaucoup de personnes qui se
reconnaissent pas du tout en moins de
temps puis perdre que moi fut un temps
parce que j'ai bloquer systématiquement
parce qu'il y en avait trop un trou
nombre qui m'écrivait la shit le fait
que sais je sais black blocs turbo
j'ai tout bloqué à peu près 500
personnes c'est toi qui dealent avec
laquelle jamais avant mais surtout j'ai
commencé parce que les affaires qu'il
serait trop lourde en fait ce qui
m'agresse le plus c'est qu'à mettons g
qui j'écris un tweet puisque quelqu'un
qui me suit pau le qui volent chéri et
rajouter sa phrase comme le chèque comme
tu me suis peuple le joaillier réponse
il voir partager ma réponse mangeait pas
je prends pas sa réponse pour dire je
vois si je sais que je lui dis à lui
jamais lui comme j'étais gamin du box
mais c'est comme si fait comme ok mais
là y'a quelqu'un qui me parle je veux
dire à tout le monde
j'entends me parle de ça chez vous ce
que j'ai répondu je le sais tu fais
comme je profite dell'abate le bloc noir
et ses soeurs exhortant la réponse où va
le haut et je répondais petit truc un
peu baveux le voleur historiques ou
dis-je
je sais comme l'autre jour je me mettais
un goût qui s'est même attaqué sur je
sais pas trop quoi le jeu d'aller voir
sa photo de profil il y avait quand
c'était juste un vieux vélo dans un
garage le plus beau vélo juste parler de
lui parler son vélo sans pain parce
qu'ils me disaient jeter comme mais ton
vélo
quel bazar tu le décris
alors j'aimerais vraiment ce qu'on parle
plus profondément de ton vélo encore
c'est de l'ironie il mais pour moi c'est
comme ma façon de 2,2 potron embarqué
dans la galère un peu détaché
salif est figé défaut comme quoi le
pare-brise de velocity carmel attaque
mot poppy freiner ce phénomène que je
pourrai jamais comprendre le team et on
t'aime fort du mot de jean thomas jobin
besoin d'être anti crise mapad c'est des
fois même des fois on sortait sur
facebook une recette vegan c'est moche
vegan puis on sortait une recette et
gagnent du groupe facebook puis
quelqu'un qui vient comme entente là
cette crise devait gagnent de marbre
manger de la marde 6 mai 20 n'y a rien
qui force avec le ramène à mon peuple
syrien et à l'aide à cette recette le
probable que je veux nuancé en disant
c'est juste faux son comportement mais
si métiers y est ami avec quelqu'un qui
soit rage qui lui commandent les élus
voient ça sans fil de nouvelle fois sa
femme c'est la fin des viguier deux
jours après j'ai juste besoin de masse
qui regardent et déjà certain qu'il
oblige à faire sur le comportement
surtout la tête confie de match parce
qu'ils ont encore plus de talent swift
fait que les gens beaucoup d'animosité
aussi donc là je pense que c'est tout et
triples et quadruples et le point de vue
à une série de sociaux avec moi je suis
vraiment beaucoup plus j'écris en ce
moment je jeu fit pas là bas y pensent à
semer mais mes fans en général sont
super respectueux en gentil mais on sait
que là ce moment je fais comme je te
pousse observateurs ces réseaux sociaux
que kelly l'on attend tous de temps à
table comme j'ai fait jacques
aujourd'hui mais où je voyais qu'il y
ait un tweet par parme
pas trop à ce match comme moi qu'ils on
dirait que je déménage refusant de peau
de balle ou ailleurs je fais comme moi
qui ont regardé ça tu fais bien tu fais
bien c'est vraiment une période qui est
qui wild qui lourde pour rien si je
comprends pas
en fait je comprends qu est ce qui se
passe mais à stx et direct c'est dur à
concevoir
mettons que tu fais les ports et les
comptes des réseaux sociaux en ce moment
là dans nos vies respectives le il ya
vraiment vraiment plus de conviction
legg mason et puisqu'on en soirée comme
un blog de maternité puis elle a reçoit
des messages étaient des gens qui
quittaient que la façon qu'à l' élève
ses enfants ou ses xy prises de
positions qu'elle prend j'ai dit y
réfléchir vraiment c'est quoi l'impact
positif vers ses coûts et l'impact
négatif en ce moment des réseaux sociaux
pour toi ou pis si ces horreurs mingli
négatif fait le pot à wright débile à
hammam à réécrire d'après as fait tu as
raison je viens de faire une liste pige
me déconnecte pendants existant parce
que ça m'amène plus rien strictement
plus rien
ils se disent qu'une fois que je pose la
vraie question qu'est-ce que ça m'amène
en ce moment qui reste rien seppi
surtout qu'en ce moment ce n'est pas que
tellement lourde puis collectivement
mais aussi individuellement pour
plusieurs personnes ce qui en aucun cas
vif tough l'hectare pertes d'emplois
puis des compagnies kirov speed des pays
du monde qui perdent des gens de leur
entourage pour la maladie ou même des
les cancers dont les traitements sont
retardés tisser si lourd collectivement
et individuellement
sauf que justement comme tu dis en ce
moment si les réseaux sociaux sont le
moindrement plus négatifs que positifs
mais allez y jeter fin de match servie
exactement ce que réduit le niveau de
stress ou si les réseaux sociaux sont un
rappel constant du fait que ça va mal
parce qu'en ce moment ce n'est que ce
que ce défaut et des bribes de
positivisme du monde que tu fais craquer
ça fait du bien
les exceptions melchiot que vivent 25
nouveaux morts au québec
les chimpanzés sont enlevés de la liste
des animaux en voie de disparition
mille morts là rien de positif c'est
l'autre pour les chimpanzés météo
annoncée c'est lolo fais quoi moi j'ai
comme panon aussi j'apprends de poser
réseaux sociaux parce que je n'ai pas
pris de pause techniquement c'est je
réponds quand même où je peux répondre
ou une box mais c'est plus long puis je
mets moins de gags parce que 11 ans je
le fil pas d'astana s'est ainsi pas
parce que je suis déprimé il s'agit des
bottes que je trouve plus tough comme
tout le monde mais c'est juste qu'on
dirait que ça fait ainsi mettons je pose
comme je les réflexes de deux balles et
qu'il répond au souhait de répondre une
petite affaire à un commentaire mais là
ça fait en sorte que je plus ces réseaux
sociaux donc je suis plus témoin de tout
là quoique si tu mets moins de guerre
goût mais moins de talent immense - ton
fils mais tu vois moins toutes les
négatifs qui popent parce que moi je me
j'essaie de répondre montre le fait -
dont je vous ai exposé - suis déjà
converti un vecteur en forme et en lui
répondant mais c'était juste le frustre
encore plus maintenant
bombay où c'est arrivé quand même que ça
mais ça va pas que ce soit relié à une
discussion mais c'est arrivé une fois
que j'ai pris un peu plus le temps que
la personne parce que son attaque se
sentait pas trop me in spirit focus du
bon mais puis j'ai juste parce qu'en
général je réponds jamais genre oui mais
m mais passe au suivant si tu m'aimes
pas aussi des genres il y en a d'autres
mais là j'ai juste été un peu baveux
ironique mais pas trop
plus ils m'ont répondu puis là je dis
regarde dans sa société
didier personne n'était pas un gars à
temple consommer moins du monde les
attend pour me suit qu'est ce qui se
passe on roddick et c'est correct de
droite promet cependant j répondu j'ai
aucun problème avec les gens qui
m'aiment pas j'ai absolument où je veux
pas faire unanimité jarroudi maso des
focales monde se font agresser vous
aiment vraiment parce que ça me fait un
peu rire mais je vois si quelqu'un
m'attaque mais je vous réponde baveuse
maj une brodeuse du 6 ie6 midi ben je le
droit de m'exprimer liberté d'expression
sont quand même beaucoup je dois de
triple iq et ses défauts de me garder
qui figent parce que tu leur réponds
pour calmer le jeu je vois plus sauf que
toi je pluie rené que pendant l'attaqué
mais ce qui est le mari avait acquis qui
comme on a eu une discussion qui a été
un peu papa super sympathique mais qui
acheminent et de sa durée à un son
horrible il m'a écrit une semaine plus
tard un qui m'a dit écoute des
discussions vont quand même fait
réfléchie gelé m'excuser j'ai répété
truc c'est pas pour moi
mais effectivement c'était pas ce
n'était pas nécessaire puis j'y repense
himself
je vois pas en quoi ça peut m'apporter
quelque chose de tel communiqué que
j'aimais poisson j'ai appris à gérer
pont-du-casse et j'apprécie vraiment un
ton message est utile jusqu'à sa rancune
ça me fait plaisir que tu sujet ce
cheminement à l'opie je mens suspense
pour que je gagne un fait mais je pense
quand même que peut-être qui ici ou
valises joue sur le fait que ouais t'es
y en a qui peuvent réfléchir à leurs
actions dans ce sens qui témoignent des
fois je
avec le recul sur ma journée je me dis
ok mais cela c'est ma vie je me chicaner
avec 1
ils ont deux gardes en vendant les
travaux dans mon coin que je n'ai
vraiment plus capable des embouteillages
constat je déménage et je peux même plus
bouger il n'y avait même plus de 2 g
même plus de porte de sortie de suffit
j'ai dit ça mais ça tu réveil à 6h du
matin aussi ou aux aidants mais
l'héroïne de sa grossesse à gruchet mais
je me suis mangé coûteux l'application
comme la location
moi j'écoute beaucoup dé la méditation
guidée le nom c'est moi j'écoute juste
des gens bien ça j'appelle cela publie
sur les feuilles
ces averses et tombe sur des feuilles
paris puis moi je accous les travaux
commencent à 6 à 7 heures le matin j'ai
mon haut parleurs blues et je mets mon
camp d'altitude dans ma chambre c'est
tentant hélas la verse le lait dans une
jungle complète
nous sommes à 100 sinon une vie toute la
nuit ou juste le matin 4 j'ai commencé
l'application s'appelle l'option white
noise qui est juste comme une télé qui
fait comme je vous mets ton des
ambiances sonores comme vol un avion
fait le c'est comme sauter dans un avion
peut tenter l'espèce de bruit d'aviron
le tout le temps l'autre attlee plat
lite des feux rouges et le train je veux
sortir vraiment la même application de
l'insee une nuit citadine moins exacts
le contingent des voitures passaient
plus des fautes a comme but classe
chaque salarié pas bon lui karkwa c'est
ça c'est vrai lac c'est grave je sais
qu'ils disent mais au genre pluie sur un
toit tall âgées pas seul la gmv mg
orages gt spyder sa basse a raconté
houdan je suis par rapport à vos pièces
les pieds
bref chaque année avec le doubs penser
ça mais en fait c'est juste que
l'acheter parce que des fois il ya des
ouvriers qui font des trucs mais dans le
secteur il ya chapeautée par une autre
juridiction et d'autres mondes font des
travaux qu'il a l'option que j'avais
pour monter chez nous qui était la seule
option que je connaissais pas ce que je
le sais que tu es barre et là il y avait
eu très tôt je peux pas passer avec là
je m'en veux prendre la rue suivant
market n'est pas la nommer la personne
habite comme je déménage pour l'aja
rythme monte sur market le joug valley
sur pauline julier pour arriver aux 18
soit 14 puis la ji pauvret 15 mètres à
faire il ya deux employés de la ja la
circulation qui ont dès lors de soirées
cetera
puis ils savent je pense que souvent
fait toujours des tiges folie de tuer
leur dis merci de la main le terrain
j'avais comme un rendez vous chez nous
pour une visite d'un évaluation
hypothécaire avec le foot juste par le
20ème ait levé il y avait personne en
plus le puits ils n'ont jamais voulu une
zone de paul droit je sais que je suis
va émettre le site où je reprenne
papineau ça va être 45 minutes à
l'ironie saint joseph puis garnies et
bloqué je sais pas si vous me traitez en
ce moment les 20 gars qui endossa qui me
dit qu'on se fasse je peux pas monter
market voulait repos ni papineau 20e
j'étais vraiment fâché fake je suis
vraiment aussi le temps j'ai pas d'idée
affaires méchante mais après je suis
allé m'excuser talent et les rebonds les
deux je pense quand même que j'avais
raison sur le fond mais pas sur ma façon
de le communiquer ou jetés et y sont
mais restait comme la marmite a été
pleine de facto les salaires y voir
individuellement je leur ai dit je suis
désolée
ça fait six mois si bruyant on est pris
en otage le j'avais un rendez vous j'ai
manqué mon rendez vous il faut que je
remette mon rendez vous à cause de son
apparition à ce culte droit j'avais
raison et fâché mais je suis quand même
allé m'excuser parce que ça met ton jean
thomas jobin
kippen l'ena quiros le temps sur le pas
de la chose là
les apparentes au monde au contraire ces
six belges plein je peux avoir le verbe
un peu à ça c'est bon ça
les défauts mais je suis capable de
m'aimer mais mes mots peuvent sortir
qu'en une façon assez fluide et un feu
roulant de phrases ne qui finit publie
le monde comprend pas toutes les
branches du pis à attiches pas contents
mais là ça ce que je peux jamais je vous
dirais je suis sur le point de tuer donc
moi j'ai plus sur la vie tu vas les
majestueuses atmosphère de forêt pluie
battante pluie légère feu de camp
clapotis du ruisseau et que la pause 10
10 2 me alors est ce ce cadre c'est fait
mais très - ouais effectivement 110 m
haies le plus fréquemment possible comme
ce ton cerveau fait une association puis
s'endort
quand tu mets fait plus tulle mais
plutôt sérieuses et mieux cela ce 6e à
l'accession vous savez plus sur les
feuilles
je me sens surtout depuis que barroso
maintenant ça non dallier plus où il va
s'il s'en excuser cascades devons savoir
lui trop paisible c'est bien lille calme
surf au large de l'océan que ça ça du
coup ça me colle et sa liste elle offre
ses mots le bruit blanc ccc se poser là
dans le cerveau c'est que ça masque
aussi toutes les autres
ouais c'est ça le sélectionneur qui
s'appelle chute bb os
c'est comme si tu disais oh ça sert à
rien en bref un must have et orages
bruire aux baleines à bosse chat
ronronnant mouvement de ventilateurs
grillon du soir battements d'choeur
machine à laver à grande eau choix quand
même une bonne mais moi j'ai commencé
après ce qui est ce le ph qui dégueule
[Rires]
remarquer partenariat doit être pas
choisi n'importe qui bouleversa nichols
et botteur parce que tu as été un peu
plus sollicité pour être vu ouais je
sais pas si loin si vous autres vous
l'annoncer maintenant je fais c'est non
mais ok qu'ils essaient sms et comme
étant des filles alors moi je dis pas ce
que je fais juste écouter ce qu'il a dit
je le contenu m'intéresse
ladite 606 m'endormir mais ça va il ya
plusieurs sortes c'est marseille en a
qui passe non ma pauvre il y en a qui
parlent fait claire c'est oui
effectivement été porté à comprendre ce
qu'est ce qu'a dit maintenant mettre en
oeuvre et que c'est juste de manipuler
des objets puis en fait c'est juste une
ambiance de fou comme pour ouvrir comme
ça pour vrai je faisais j'écoute pas ça
pour le plaisir maintenant mais j'écoute
nom magique tout ça avant de me coucher
ma tombe
mais qu'est ce que c'est les côtes
version vidéo ou audio vidéo vidéo mais
c'est un peu comme l'équipe d'al ahd moi
je veux voir ce qui a fait mal aux
casseurs à et crayons l'écoutent vidéo
mais je la finit pas je le finis par ben
man et je fais juste comme déposer mon
seul à côté je l'écoutais un but
l'afer qui est grosse a en fait c'est
que les grecs dans ta tête tu est
programmée à ne pas t'endormir passe trè
pas que c'est on sait les rues toute la
nuit ne le font pas ou que tu as fait
apprécier la vidéo suivante il
s'embarqua thématique fac est fait mais
les vidéos sont assez longue qui est
souvent été après une demi-heure de
récemment la même séquence vraiment ça
ne vient juste couché dans mon lit des
fois je m'endors le postillon je
comprends j'ai ensuite le gros 4 à oued
dans ton lit puis a pas d'armé a annoncé
le tuc let's hope rando chaude survie
non moins tu as tu des problèmes de
sommeil souvent goubel là c'est moins
épais pour pas parler trop parce que ça
va ça va me provoquer à ravoir
non mais j'ai eu des périodes où ses
ouailles tester dessus le stream ce que
tu sais ça je pense que j'ai perdu mes
deux parents il ya trois autres façons
assez rapprochées puis l'a bien été
malade avant puis je pense que c'était
c'est beaucoup il ya mon deuil
c'est dans ce sens que c'est
sûrement vraiment déprimé à cause de
deuil
je suis parfois encore un peu l'oeil
c'est un très long mais je pense à vous
en sorte que toutes les petites
réflexions qui popent dans ma tête mais
là c'est comme si ces glucides et tout
en même temps de le regrettes tu fais
tout ce que tout dire ça je n'ai pas de
regret majeur mais dans un deuil de
toujours des des réflexions du jeu
je rêvais à mes parents défaut je
faisais des cauchemars plus de foot au
début ce s'il la perd à face et que tu
te dis débute deuil des futures est
bâtie par un petit appareil ont l'air
bien dans ton rail petit réveil plus de
ce qu'annonce ont pu lui c'est
maintenant la star quand je rêve qu'il
le règle soit beau ou triste je suppose
secoué en me réveillant dans ce rush
thabeet suivent mais fait que je pense
que mon insomnie stay beaucoup beaucoup
relié à soultz puis j'ai essayé une
tonne d'affaires mais c'est vraiment ce
qui marche le plus c'est l'application
comme depuis j'essaie amendé le cannabis
sous forme de duels j'avais un
consommateur de potes mais le cannabis
sous forme d'huile je pense à edéa j'en
prends plus parce que je dors mieux mais
ça a aidé à casser le style des fois
juste le fait d'essayer quelque chose
l'effet placebo défaut de tester quelque
chose et comme content ça va marcher
c'est comme vous dire mais les yeux de
cannabis que je m'étais fait recommandé
ça a marché deux trois nuits de suite
puis là je n'ai plus vraiment besoin
mais on dirait que ça m'a quand même
juste donner confiance et que je peux
dormir puis je
gelée cannabis ça ça m'a vraiment aidé
mon sommeil
g mais mais tout fait pas vraiment
décennies taxus d'une ambiance au sol
non sauf que souvent je dois vraiment
légèrement hockey avec le moins de bruit
je me réveille pitié quand je me
réveille je me rêvais que les bulls à
151 sens quelque chose qui me réveille
ce genre de la suite je me rendors pôle
web mais peut-être que tu fais ce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle un seul gars
comme moi j'ai fait somme lui c'était
une scène des plus globale mais j'ai
longtemps fait de l'insomnie du petit
matin en à peine deux réveils double
titre adore puce et un peu bizarrement
dormait mais je me réveillais double je
me rendors mes pulls c'est comme si ma
tête était comme qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
que je fais ce que j'aime et en 4k titre
est venue de la nuit les tifos que tu
faut pas que cech ton ciel faut pas que
tu te sois mode l'offre je laisserai
l'exprimera lui les cannabis et que ça
faisait quand je me réveillais mais que
je fais encore un peu mollo maintenant
dans mon sommeil je retombe et chute le
système devait payer mais comme mon
cerveau est vide
en fait je me rends compte que tu étais
pas genre à toute vitesse non c'est sur
un trend risqué parce que c'est la paix
la femme mais quand tu travailles tu
dois penser à quelque chose qui s'en
vient le tango c'est dominer qui pense à
sa tondeuse un hasard avec la vie que je
pense à ça mais sur ses ordinateurs si
nous voulons être capables en chef très
fiers fiers de cet épisode
depuis combien de temps que aux
habitants depuis juin ouais juin et 7
juillet la danse classe découverte qui
gît le com fait à cause de comment ça
c'est fait
je me suis séparé puis j'avais une
chambre dans mon appart puissant la
partie qui quitteront cher pour être
seul fait que je dis est demande adams
est en tête tout était ça moi je t'ai
dangereusement avec un colloque kijiji
justement hockey qui quitta ben ketai
ben correct puis le lac ohrid d'arrivée
puis j'étais comme one tu mets ton badin
heureusement qui me coûte un versus la
chambre chez ph qui me coûterait la
moitié du temps avec quelqu'un salut
salut marc-antoine mais pas que je dois
je pense que ça serait le fun
même si j'avais très bel appartement
métro beaubien c'est sparadrap mais
faites-le la colocation veut vos pires a
bien bossé par bien on sait que dsk en a
un qui un petit peu plus speak and spell
qui reproche à l'autre bpa chez qui
clama le le fruit que d'ordre de ce fait
le a indiqué georges tron et mais j'ai
façon ici j'ai passés par le port tanger
med en cohabitation et je touche je
pense que les deux on est assez vieux
puis on se connaissait pour avoir ma
chambre est dégueulasse mais le résultat
c'est bien parce que c'est comme une
forme d'empathie envers ton ton coup là
seulement ce qu'ils retenaient depuis
qu'on a
9-10 ans - pitié mettons nos véhicules
toutes sortes d'aventurés pph les
rapports sexuels fréquents en afrique
africains se complique pour brest où on
fait des blagues que tu dis on est un
couple ce point là on n'est pas un
couple c'est une petite farce mais pis
même kitty
on est loin de se raser le dos mais tant
pis d'escrimé le dos en fait on est très
peu de contacts physiques monde php 7,7
faudrait peut-être que ted a soufflé son
nom mais par exemple c'est comme si vu
qu'on s'est connus spar jeunes à une
époque où à ce qui m'attend sert pas la
meilleure amie je n'ai commencé on se
bat pas de nombreux non plus parce que
ya jamais eu un moment où est ce que dit
elle compte assez vieux pour faire ce
fait qu'on dit quand cordes comme des
enfants fassent quelque chose est bon
mais rami que je te laisse juger qui a
trait rouge annonce à la main non plus
loin mais des douches communes disposent
d'un dôme amendé mais tant que tu envie
d'ouvrir un peu plus le lira tranchera
physique ce que je te suggère si l'année
les robinets non non c'est la méthode de
thé pour l'économie d'eau chaude à
comprenons synchronisons notre douche
ouais ph c'est pas pour te voir le corps
c'est parce qu'on va sauver d'auchan une
question grâce à l'effet que soit leur
peut-être qu'ils vont faire corps la
suggestion de l'automobile
maintenant je suis le vigeant dans votre
discussion ça se pourrait que sexy mais
je vois je vois réécrira dorment sur
instagram joey tirs d'autres doutent
peut-être que peut-être que je regardais
mon doute faire à qui j'ai vraiment
besoin finalement d'une petite un petit
coup de tondeuse est prête à étendre le
dos mais avec la tondeuse taza comme ce
serait le plus précis
peut-être que son dos va devenir dans
half actifs à sa santé
ce genre de réflexions lorsque ça de
cette pop souvent en tâtant est ps que
des fois tu l'était je ne faut pas les
terres les titres qu'on fait mais
maintenant on a envie de tous les jours
ce qui est des fois t'es comme dans un
meeting quand même important plus les
quelque chose qui passe dans ta tête tu
fais comme peut-être que c'est pas le
bon c'est rare que je les trie bas
jusqu'à 1 6 fois par contre qui je
voulais rouil mais sa frappe à deux
tables malaise mais les affaires que je
me dis c'est fait un malaise pour des
raisons x y soit je peux le trier mais
me créer des malaises jeudi être pas de
malaise à créer des malaises dans ce
sens
ben oui pas été levés tous les jours
mais tant qu 1,4 manque quelque chose de
plus 110 encore prête le pas ce que je
peux à quel point tu as des trucs comme
prêtre dans ta vie mais c'est quand tu
étais dans un moment où est ce que le
malaise est pas source d'humour me
tendre ou les gens qu'ils voient là
dessus mais j'ai quand même
ou oui j'aime ça testez les au pouvoir
c'est quoi les limites d'un groupuscule
maintenant le jeu dans un effectif des
événements mondains personnes que je
connais pas tant mais on dirait que des
fois je vais tester les eaux juste pour
voir les réactions souvent ça fait en
sorte que ça peut plein des groupes
d'inconnus besoin c'est comme si les
niaiseries que je vous disais devient
comme une façon de
de créer un contact ou que deux
personnes se disent que c'est bizarre
mais la science que maintenant je fais
pas souvent le trident saas comme le jeu
ça sur pauvres c'est quelque chose qui
peuplent mais même à personne on dit que
dans le monde dont le joueur a plus
attention mes cahiers un petit groupe le
ou le chic ça fait quelques semaines
avec pas de casse mais du quotidien ben
là je trouve ça le fun ça fait juste
créer des réactions organiques peuvent
être soit drôle ou bizarre mais je vois
tout le temps essayez au moins de garder
la loupe sur la situation puis si je
vois qu'il ya quelque chose qui passe
mal mais je vois le dédramatiser
si jamais dramatique mais je vois là
léger en l'accusant ou s'est fait que
quand même assez un autre qui kills
phone dans ton show de seppi
c'est que peu importe le style gags
mettons pour avec un gros rire matière
fait ta job en danger
si un jour damas live ça rit pas trop
c'est c'est drôle aussi
qu'en pense que je faisais parce que
c'est un personnage est un peu oui le
plaignant un malaise puisque comme ce
qui est drôle c'est vrai que mes
détracteurs aux crises qui peut perdre
non mais c'est des fois j'ai un réflexe
des fautes dans mon show mon metteur en
scène le dif est à six-fours chasse
attention aussi à ne pas trop faire du
d'auto dérision ou d'auto bashing
d'accuser le fait que ses rivaux - c'est
parti
whaou 2 0 crise j'ai largué la ouvrir de
pitié ou si je le fais faut que je fasse
attention pas trop le fasse a marché je
sais que ça marche mais faudra que ça
d'une béquille non plus - j'essaie de
faire attention le pommeau quatrième
chouchou c'est à dire les sanguins
je vais essayer de pas trop dire à celle
là je l'échappée la 425e de ta liste
avec les dix ans c'est juste un
parchemin qui des revues ouais je sais
où je suis rendu là 426 et une bonne
lecture
les dessins et bien fait voilà merci
merci merci
c'est parce que vous le rappelle
artistes non mais c'est parce que
c'était une firme de marketing de brenda
fait de surf exotiques en interne puis
je sais même pas ce équipe je m'appelle
même pas c'est quoi le nom de la firme
film en contact et elle y travaille plus
le fait que vraiment pas dire ça parce
que je suis passé qui comme moi je
réussis de décortiquer vincci qui bat
j'aimerais ça fait tu es à gauche a été
grand ce que ça dit c'est sont tellement
symbiotique ses 2 go là que leurs
pulsations cardiaques sont synchronisées
son vous ou encore comment un coeur
commun puisque c'est les pulsations
cardiaques comme si c'était nous sommes
le même coeur la prédation
c'est beau ça qu'est la personne qui qui
qui fait ça les logos les photos les
dessins ont été fabriquées je m'habitue
le logo a été fait par marianne
plaisante
bon ben marianne plaisance j'aimerais ça
que dans les commentaires sur les
écoutes présentement quelque à vienne
analyser mon analyse
ok là john des vidéos
action la whey le tout de suite réagi à
notre logo puis elle profite de youtube
réaction d'attenté en tête que tu
profonde réaction sa vie idéale mal le
reste de ma vie ça me regarde dans un
miroir miroir mon agent doit m'appeler
ben je rencontre je peux pas faut je
réagisse à la dix-huitième réaction sera
rien elle a commenté ma réaction 17 et
ça m'a froissé ce cas le 10 août
ce qu'ils préfèrent des podcasts
réaction à d'autres pas de casquette au
fait tu as tu dois passer donc commander
votre casque et qui a déjà été fait ça
donne ma performance ou béton le ceser
que mettons qu'on voit mortaises ou que
- choix c'est ce qu'on voit le portage
commentaires pour vrai et et s'est rendu
en marche tellement votre vidéo il ya
des vidéos réactions qui ont plus de
d'ecoute que les vidéos originales comme
la réaction est plus populaire que la
source
si je faisais se remettant j'aurais pas
la finale parce que plusieurs le font
general motors et c'est pour cela que
des podcasts des discussions on a
inventé mais web en fait j'ai
l'impression que pour être papa pour
faire sa valise et mets toutes mes
performances n'avaient pas de casque ou
tons chauds peu importe quoi bon show
des racks faire des réactions aux
affaires te fait jouer bach ou six teams
et on te fait une vidéo réaction auto
qui réagit à père poule mais c'est moi
ouais c'est pour ça qu'à viser pour vrai
moi qui aime moi c'est ce que je regarde
c'est sûr j'ai tellement écouté cette
série là que j'écouterai les réactions
volontiers mais faudrait que ça apporte
plus en vrai que c'est pas les métaux
que je tombe d'âge pour bunny chronique
des fautes droits des quelque chose de
robert policiers mais comme père poule
c'était comme une fiction on dirait ça
me remercie aussi mes mais banalisée -
podcast
bonne idée non mais commenter ou des
épisodes de se voir commenté par jean
thomas jobin façon incroyable hu a
effectivement mais pour que ça serait
déjà un peu et si je le fais un gag puis
si vous avez plus ni ce qu'il est maître
méditation guidée
oui tribalisation guider les gens savent
c'est quoi le référent est assez claire
de méditation guidée j'ai pas hostile
aux débats cohérent sur toi mais tandis
que sur les gens et en tout cas le
référent meilleurs qu'ils l'ont pas fait
qu il a faite il ya des gens qui
écoutent route vers le référent grave
qui m'a peut-être ça près de digoin
certaines personnes doivent écouter
qu'est-ce qui tu dis que tu es tu écoute
écoute population 2 débrayable avec mon
ami julian veulent imposer la feccom
balle et on écoute ce soit on écoute ce
geste comme une femelle alpha au fait
que la fin du gaj les quads ci parce que
ça me force à l'écouté wallemme ce que
que je commence le cuivre pour ceux que
ça à m'écouter commenté inscrits à
écouter cette année j'ai eu des épisodes
vient écouter peut-être trois quêtes
épisode c'est quoi dans l'analyse
d'occupation baisse et les agressions
attend qu'ils sont restés jeu septembre
un ton cerveau frc chose le jem date est
interdit c'est tout c'était ma
déclaration d'humour
simon dumas va alors en fait je suis pas
mal de l'année que j'écoutais plus
d'épisodes à date
mais en fait moi je trouve au delà de
d'analyser les liégeois les joueurs je
regarde comme un puce sociologiquement
comment les gens se comportent un peu
c'est une chose qui m'a intéressé la
télé réalité c'est la même chose avec
serveuses sont intéressants mais ça va
oui c'est plus la stratégie fait que je
dirais quand yao des pales stratégie
oserait qui logent déjà à cause que j'ai
tellement
un de gris de gris intenses des analyses
de stratégie assure véreux qui est pas
mal plus poussés parce que le jeu est
vraiment différent quand il parle de
stratégie à audi on dirait que les gens
aient envie de bavay le jeu coûte que
coûte la vie à julian franchement
stratégie bobos mais j'aime voir les
interactions entre les gouttes les
filles les négociations qu'ils font mais
pas tant de niveaux stratégique mais
qu'il décortique comment c'est quoi la
perception qui tu penses qu'ils m'ont
préféré ou a préféré je dirais que je
l'écoutent avec un niveau d'ironie un
peu dans ma tête mais ça n'empêche pas
que je trouve que tout est bien fait je
trouve ça c'est j'écoute et puis je
m'emmerde pour nous le sujet je
l'écouterai peut-être pas seul mais
quand tu as quelqu'un vie qu'ils
commencent et c'est pour ça que j'ai
l'impression corrige moi je me trompe
corrigez moi mais j'ai l'impression que
comme la cote des côtes de od est pas si
grosse versus le tapage que ça fait ces
réseaux se fait que je n'ai passé aucun
signe un phénomène communautaire dont on
a envie d'en parler on a envie de bâches
et on a envie de se moquer de charles
keeling j'ai même pas vu lui dit je sais
que j'ai fait le job sur toutes les
touches du mont l'agente à l'alaric et
j'ai dit en une semaine charles fait
parler plus de lui que moi à trop
tourner laisse passer les péniches et
j'ai pensé de façon jalousie mesquine
c'était juste une constatation c'est
possiblement
c'est vrai puis je remarque je suis du
monde qui en parle visiblement sur
twitter je vois des commentaires passé
ça prouve que c'est un show qui réussit
parce que mettons des fois je vous lis
que je comprends qu'il est peut-être du
monde hip hop budget watch et ou qui en
régissent mettant les côtes d'écouté ont
l'air de 6 autour de 450 mais tu as
l'impression que c'est un million cinq
cent mille qu'ils écoutent la façon que
ça c'est discuter
je pense qu'un phénomène communautaire
de s'effonder coûtant à ganges leur
peuple et culture en gagne mais juste le
fait d'écouter avec quelqu'un d'autre
10 en parler après puis de débat vu
quelque chose qui s'est passé ou de de
commenter le choc et d'histoire de la
meinau gifle qu'il y avait j'ai pas vu
cet épisode l'homme je n'ai entendu
parler de mon fils comme qu'est ce qu'on
fait on fait une pétition est quelque
chose de tir de fascinant à le phénomène
sociologique qui qui qui apparaît pas si
gros mais qui exponentielle à cause que
tout le monde va passer définitivement
un phénomène social au québec au chèque
chaque saison de démontrer cette celle
ci encore plus le pourquoi du temps non
mais du coup ça se passe au québec ou
non mais de qui ça devient un genre de
prétexte pour parler de toutes sortes
d'affaires pour ouvrir la discussion sur
la partie des comportements des
candidats ouvrent vraiment un débat de
société sur mettons sait manier de chars
la question ici aux troupes
s'autoproclame féministe et il a bon qui
le ca ou l'édition sûr on peux-tu faire
c'est un tango de juste dire je suis
féministe de membres plus qu il dit en
coupe à paroles un peu à la vie et qui
parle du fait que le blessé se plaint
les gens commandent que c'est ça devient
vraiment un espèce de truc couesque et
on l'analyse à travers plein de prisme
qui fait que finalement à partir des
quelque chose de d'un peu compte premier
degré puis arrête vite paraître vip
tiges thomas avec un concept
peut-être trouvé l'amour métier vraiment
de base la société situe vraiment mais
vraiment qui c'est le en général non le
tir mais finalement péter les métaux il
ya eu aussi la tout l'aspect ti
inclusion diversité corporelle sera tout
à être une grosse conversations au
dessous est ce que la production a bien
géré ce dossier le ou non est ce qu'on
est prêt à tant que société de voir
différents types de personnes à
télévision d'ananas c'est super
pertinentes à partir desquels nous a
vraiment cave comme on avance tout ceci
dit comment ok j'ai rien à dire
humoriste josiane au bouchon avez vous
vu son enfant que son billet facebook là
dessus non sur justement parce qu'elle
est à parler de julie pia 10 et 6 ans
que son tour son twist pas un tweet
statut facebook mais je trouve ça
tellement bien équipe puis ça me faisait
penser à ça quand tu dis que des fois ça
stimule une réflexion puis ça fait en
sorte qu'on peut faire avancer quelque
chose alors qu'à la base le truc peut
paraître vide ça ça crie à faire trotter
hamster de la réflexion puis l'a10 et
ben ok c'est bien c'est bien de mettre
de l'avant plan la diversité corporelle
mais si la fille est tout à jamais
choisi pied tout le temps parce que
c'est le public qui regarde mais les
gars veulent pas ça va vraiment la garde
et le j'ai pas tout vu l'émission ça
aide vraiment à cette question j'ai
l'impression que ça a été tu te tue
aussi le teaser par gordon pinsent c'est
vraiment moi je pense que c'est pas
l'émission pour faire ce je pense que
l'occupation 2 ça a toujours été des
personnes qui font extrêmement attention
à leur apparence physique effectué les
gars musclés des feuilles avec dessert
fait depuis le début puis pour changer
ça faut que ça change au casting pied
puis pour changer au casting faut qu' il
y avait beaucoup de monde qui se
présentent aux options
représente la diversité corporelle je
pense pas que ce soit le cas puis en
parle un petit peu aux membres de la
preuve daudet de cette année c'est un
peu ce qui se passe ici on a pas de
diversité corporelle qui se présentent
aux options il y en a intéressant assez
pour les amener dans le shoot fait
l'émission à partir du casting est pas
là je pense pas que c'est l'émission
pour faire ce je pense que si tu veux
faire ça faut que ce soit un autre
émission soit quelque chose ça doit être
ça pourrait être intéressant une saison
mais c'est sûr qu'il peut pas dire
sincèrement dans leur demande de
candidature mais que là c'est vraiment
une saison axée sûr on y vote dans des
castings qu'on a jamais eu de même
qu'elle n'est même pas un casting qui
ont déjà eu en juste du monde juste mon
côté j'avais fait ça serait vraiment ça
pour être vraiment intéressant puis ça
ferait en sorte qu'ils n'auraient
peut-être pas un ou une qui ressortirait
du lot s'ajuste poker dépendamment de
positivement ou négativement comme
acquis qu'est ce qu'il ou elle fait là
d'un point de vue qu'à signer mais aussi
était ici étaient tous et toutes
atypique pour une certaine raison
lesaffre est peut-être une homogénéité
dans le secteur
je pense pas que tu peux juste amener
quelqu'un une personne seule
c'est julie alala ultrafin sur ce que tu
vois que tout ces gars là c'est des gars
qui font attention à leur physique qui
se garde en chef sexy dance si pour toi
c'est une valeur qui est important c'est
quelque chose qui est qui et pour toi
important tu pourras pas match et avec
quelqu'un pour qui seuls les potiers ou
savoir effectif c'est comme c'est cela
le gateway qui peut pas juste amener une
personne plus fort voici la diversité
corporelle
je pense aussi qu'il ya un jeu de
c'est la poule ou l'oeuf le ts que le
public aussi est intéressé à voir un
show juste de casting aspecté puis je
pense qu'il ya une part proportion du
monde qui aime sauvegarde et encore
aujourd'hui du monde avec l'espagne puis
défilé avec les grosses boules encore en
2020 fac bien là qu'ils l'écoutent ceci
dit d'après moi de façon et que les
codes un peu pour l'aspect freak show
comme une voix un piano qu'ils
l'écoutent pour ma très premier degré
reid
j'espère que je ferai au niveau des
réactions que j'ai eu quand je sors le
dessus d'aider des personnes qui
venaient me voir en pleurant parce qu'on
n'avait pas gagné et si la blonde mon ex
pipi moitié qu'il prenait tellement
personnellement qui pleurait en nous
voyant ses amis sont investis mais je
pense aussi que tu y mets ton la
nouvelle mouture aux délégués du temple
et tout ce j'ai du temple amène au
deuxième degré justement d'humour pitt
et johnny kidd un petit peu des deux on
se moque un peu de candidates et comment
le montage effet comment la musique
choisie qu'est ce qui est montré
c'est clairement fait pour qu'on rit en
regardant ce qu'on s'amuse aux dépens de
ces gens là qui paraissent pour la
plupart faudrait bien un médecin un
petit coup c'est cholet sur certaines
des émissions tu peux checker sur
youtube la cctc sébastien benoit qui
fait dernièrement à occupation double
ainsi qu'à mme jean qui dit dernièrement
d'occupation de breaking musique un
petit peu plus fort niveau assez - t -
serge et l'échéance prennent au sérieux
et je pense qui fait qu'on l'ait coûte
encore puiqu'il de plus en plus de monde
ouvertement discuté du monde intelligent
lui demander j'écoute au début du projet
en est à cause qui est ce 2ème degré
d'humour loti en même temps je pense que
tu risques ce collègue de se moquer un
peu faire des jokes sûrs sur charles ou
à denver mais amenés à certains points
si comme rappelle toi qui est un chouïa
de montage pitié dock mais de détester
viscéralement une personne qui trouve
que tel
on le fausse garde toujours en tête que
c'est des personnages d'élise a créé
leurs personnages y en a qui le
subissent peut-être un peu parce que
c'est oublier oublie pour la nation de
la télé subissant un montage à regret
pas tant mais ça reste que ces montées
comme des personnages d'élite à survival
y en a qui ont des archétypes en douter
quand ils font un casting il sut rien
manquer des psychologues des sociologues
qui leur dira qu'il serait un bon bilan
si vous avez cet archétype la star qui
triplera sa valve et où ça risque de
faire des flammèches où il dit fait des
fois sur 20 il ya des joueurs qui moi
j'écoute des pas de casque et débriefent
les choses munich mais des joueurs qui
disent bon jeu je sais ce qu'ils ont
montré ce qu'ils ont montré ce n'est pas
ce que j'ai vécu
mais en même temps je peux pas leur
reprocher d'avoir monté seul même parce
que c'est un peu une histoire qui se
peut pour eux et il me dit moi c'est pas
demain que je l' ai vécu mais qu'as tu
acceptes de la convention de données
dans un reality show qui il ya un côté
un peu plus ce jeu à l'inter parce que
c'est les joueurs qui vote est dans le
pré c'est important mais c'est ça c'est
que il y en a qui même si ce cas tu
acceptes de participer à un show dit bah
je sais pas ça va avoir de commentaire
sauf que là où des ce qui fait en sorte
que moi je prends soin plus à la légère
point de vue ludique point de vue je les
écoute un peu plus en mode pour le
divertissement pur ou la discussion que
ça m'aide avec la personne avec qui je
l'écoutais c'est que la mettons c'est un
vote du public afin le cop qui gang lots
sont à la merci du montage de phone ou
paul von qui ont comme le charme et on
sait maintenant que son but ultime c'est
de gagner je suppose et 500000 deux ans
mais j'ai un conte 12 10 6 mi temps il y
avait su je pense un peu ce qui est
arrivé avec héloïse j'ai pas trop vu
l'histoire mais j'ai quand même et je
sis
c'est le vote du public à la fin mais je
vois je détestais en ce moment je vois
je vois je vois twiki ma game pour me
faire rattraper si c'est ce qui est plus
qui est qui
la différence j'ai l'impression avec
mettons sur verre puis occupation de le
mentionner
c'est le buzz du public parce que
admettons tu vas à survire tu joues
comme qu'un petit peu puis c'est toi qui
est en charge du jeu alain terme se
trouvait en charge des destinées qui
exhalait ce qui est plus de dommages qui
en mettant comme moi par exemple quand
je suis sorti de là c'est de dire ok à
cause de certains choix de montage j'ai
pas simplement passer à côté d'un chalet
l'éthique c'est comme si ce qui est
plutôt de chez kant sur le lutz et
accepte le fait que oui je suis sujet au
montage mais en même temps comme
quelqu'un qui a décidé pour moi que je
gagnais pasalic pas je pense qu'à odetti
en fait l'eau les gens ce plan c'est
quand c'est d'avoir trop de contrôler le
jeu bien sûr ton image qui en a dans la
peau des choses peu qu'est ce que
faisait montage clitoris j'imagine quand
même si maintenant que je suis pas toi
si tu oublié complètement les caméras
mais oui tu as être dû jouer un rôle car
pendant trois mois ammann était la
nature revient ces souches d'accord mais
quand même est ce que en fait je ne sais
pas le messie est ce que te dis blanc
des trucs tôt regretté qu' on qui ont
mis au montage que tu regrettait d'avoir
dit ce que c'est arrivé
non c'est avec quand même la loupe sur
toi-même ça ou peut-être juste que tu le
sais souvent ce sont les moments où est
ce que je dis quelque chose comme of the
week end précédent qui s'était pas la
raison d'eux
sont castés pour la vente était plus
quelqu'un de réfléchi de tête ses
épaules à connecter que ces émotions qui
vont avec tout étant l'archétype était
tête épaules pour le flou non non il
était fort mal pour le le côté feelgood
effectivement mais parce qu'une autre
différence qui on le corrige moi mais si
c'est des cages à vorey trois semaines
par mois
c'est ça parce que la différence nos
différences entre sur europe 1 par
rapport au contrôle du montage sera
retourné mettons us et moi puis là les
monteurs les producteurs ils montrent
leur histoire mais ils savent quand il
commence à la montée ils savent le début
le milieu afin qu'ils arrivent le ou la
gagnante fait qu'ils vont faire un
montage en conséquence pour qu'on
comprenne moi qui fait en sorte que
c'est ça la convention tandis que lahoud
et j'imagine quand même qui en notes qui
ont sûrement eu 10 swing de popularité
ça dit que au début il le montage suis
en fait la réaction du public parce que
tu te laisses trois semaines mais le
montage est pas fait c'est en temps réel
permettant il voit aquila le québec
parle beaucoup de charité du leader fait
que la semaine d'après au complet à
chaque fois qui dit le mot leader à
toutes les fois il faut qu on penche
vers ce qu'est pepy mon avis tu as aussi
les tiens à mes yeux comme ok le monde
commence à trouver adamo haute fait que
c'est vraiment ils s'adaptent vraiment
au public les gens m'aiment et telus ont
ramené des anciens candidats de
l'émission think pire d'autant de vue un
des gentils candidat qui arrive je
savais qu'ils partent puis nul comme dit
un an confession le qui partait
d'ailleurs sur le corps l'émission était
déjà commencé ici
fa cup beaucoup de pros et beaucoup de
kilos il faut il faut que je parte de
quoi qu'ils ont fait ce gauthier
s'adapterait
le rapidement est ce que est ce que tu a
réécouté tout après j'ai réécouté chute
après cette chaude appelons les écouter
à internet n'a pas ce qu'il y en a comme
trois semaines et qu'on l'écouté de tous
les épisodes puis j'ai réécouté ultra
dernièrement le comme panne pendant le
premier conflit non critique c'est quoi
comment tu fais pour la première fois ci
j'étais trop proche pour sa meute août
mettant tabernacle genre y ont montré
sur caen lis pas ce qui s'est passé
c'est tout le monde réagisse elle même
en écoutant l'émission la première fois
puis là c'est juste le cas je les
réputés dernièrement c'était jusqu'à un
mois on a fait ce théâtre des beaux
paysages des beaux voyages puis rien qui
me dérange et ses dents quand même
montré où j'ai comme fait l'apec le fait
que j'avais pu gagner celle ci passe à
autre chose mais après après trois
années mais ouais mais c'est le font
quand même c'est un est beau souvenir
pis quand je lire écouter il disait que
le 1er septembre dans le fond il n'y
avait plus les doigts fait que s'en
aller moi j'ai écris tu t'apprêtes jeux
fadoq hommes sont plus sur le site
est-ce qu'ils existent matériellement
c'est ce que je me les avoirs que ses
plus beaux chants puis finalement qui
travaille super pour moi c'est le lac
even qui veut me fournir des soins dvd
est d'ailleurs assez bon toi maintenant
le real esthétiquement est ce que tu
penses que dans ta vie un jour 3 face à
eux laissent pas haut et c'est mon plus
grand mais je fais ce que tu es ce que
tu t'inscris j'ai bien bougé j'ai envoyé
mon audition mais c'est parce que ça
fait pas longtemps que les canadiens
sont éligibles donc j'ai envoyé deux
vidéos d'édition et une visite guidée de
mon condo j'ai fait un montage de toutes
les fois juste pour propos que j'allais
d'un charlatan car je parle du fait que
tu m'a ressuscité
j'ai fait des téoz olivier j'avais
remercié un joueur à tout le monde en
parle qui m'ont fait de répondre à un
questionnaire sur survive heures avec
laurent une question de guillaume
question pepy qui puis-je y répond avec
j'ai fait les sous-titrés on voit que
c'est un show tv ne savent pas là j'ai
confiance la vidéo est obligée d
devenus amis que des joueurs qui en fait
survivre parce que je deviens fou oui
les photos garde t sur mon meilleur
barça là mais le premier à qui j'ai
parlé cc c'est lui qui m'en irai a
promis en fait parce qu'il comprenait
pas pourquoi j'avais autant d'abonnés
ok parfait et acheté ce package mais sa
cause que j'ai mis les les plus sûrs les
français attendent des tapis bientôt
tous genres comme j'ai encore 20 parfait
trimestre fait que tu es devenu ami avec
qui est premier il s'appelle stephen
weiss bac c'est un jeu c'est un joueur
qui a joué deux fois il ya joué deux
saisons a promis d'y revenir une saison
au score puis je répondais fois aux
joies de souvent veut surtout et hull -
qui avait bondi avant je le faisais plus
puis moi j'ai quand même pas la bonne et
surtout été un crochet bleus c'est plus
d'abonnés que les autres des fois ils
sont éduqués qui mike richards et
baudoux d'air j'y réponds aux écouteurs
toni morrison au québec puisse à pied le
lui parle français fait qu'ils ont à
l'écouté mais affable qui m'est revenu
plus tard bauza et j'écoutais jamais
fait très givre il ya plusieurs
références je n'ai pas pas d'éléments
mais ça m'a fait très intéressant a
commencé à plat côté puisque sommes
devenus amis avec trois quatre personnes
parce que j'étais allé voir des podcasts
live de deux anciens joueurs dont
l'huile qui font des pas de casse où
justement il écoute l'épisode pensez y
le débrief ensemble c'est devant public
et ehrhoff et que tu ailles voir ce que
je devais amic 3 4 personnes
je leur ai montré ma vidéo pour voir ce
qu'ils en pensent et puis on tout dire
assez sûre que tu vois un appel s'impose
et que tu vas le faire avec ta vidéo et
trois crochets moi je pense que ce qui
pour ça que je suis un peu parti en
route vers survive et avec mike pour
pratiquement réglé je pense que
maintenant mon plus gros ma plus grosse
un bus c'est mon anglais pas le fait que
je comprends à tous mais si maintenant
il ya des étapes de d'entrevue ses
besoins lol c'est je pense ma vidéo
histoire accrocheuse
je pense qu'ils peuvent être intrigué
mais qu'avec le temps de faire du feu
par l'anglais a que d'autres je pense
que je vais pouvoir juste accuser le
fait si des fois des monts m'échappe
mais il faut quand je parle anglais avec
des gens je me raconte que le niveau 2
de vocabulaire que j'ai en france et je
peux pas la cote en règle et puis je
pense que c'est pas si grave pour info
mon casting il pourrait dire mais il
faut nier comme il fait il fait il fait
étranger il peut avoir un casting qui
est divertissant qu'on n'a jamais eue
moi ma plus grande peur c'est que moi
j'étais un peu perfectionniste puis si
je le fais je veux vraiment bien faire
performer
puis je pense que j'aurai des forces et
des faiblesses mais je pense que la plus
grosse béquille ce serait mon anglais
pour la compréhension mais pour la
communication parce que c'est injuste
social sociaux stratégique mais des fois
pour pour exprimer plusieurs couches
leur couche de sensibilité de de
précisions plus de pluton langage ça
devient une arme vraiment fils là j'ai
l'impression que je serai moins aussi
point du vocabulaire pour naviguer dans
toutes les couches je pense que une
audition l'assureur c'est un peu une
forme de charme
sas qui séduisent le casque je porte mon
point de vue fille je parle d'un humain
le je pense que le thread les pros puis
versus ma vidéo d'édition là j'aurai
plus de travail à faire baisser le feu
web un des accusés le fais je sais je
monte avec les boules de travail cette
erreur mais peut-être que je peux tout à
fait prêt l'eau mais en même temps je
vieillis fait que je peux le faire à 66
mais il n'y a jamais eu de candidat
étant avec un gros axe un week-end mais
c'était parce que il ya aux états unis
en a qui ont des accents le cdd redneck
focus massa sous titre il sait puisque
anglophone quand même loi et métiers
c'est ce qui le fait que je pense que
cathay aux états unis tu es un peu plus
habitués aux différents accents fait
qu'ils comprennent quand même si mon ami
de leurs 15 ans mais il y en a qui ont
eu des gros accent mais moi je sais pas
je pense plus en plus pour le cast et je
passe pour mais j'ai l'impression que ça
pourrait me dire un peu dingue mais je
peux me tromper je peux une nouvelle
pour l'instant les radis de le plus
vieux café de sel avec un autre 72 72
c'est la première saison il s'appelait
mouloudi qui il s'est rangé à toutes
fins à 30 heures il ya en fait il est
fini spoiler désolé ceux qui s'apprêtent
actuelle et il s'est rendu vraiment très
très loin
puis après la saison est ce que c'est
encore une trop populaire comme chaud ou
d'un pass les couverts saison c'était la
plus grosse affaire sa planète toujours
parler que dessus mais la cote d'écouté
donner une idée les codes des contes
c'est plus du tout les mêmes façon de
juger parce qu'ils enregistrent appuyé
le benchmark sur internet c'est plus
comptabilisés pareil sauf qu'ils gagnent
toujours leur times la aux états unis
encore mercredi 26 à 10 dans les ailes
quand ça sent les coups puis même si
j'avais accès à la saison au complet
tu es lecture le ferai pas je le ferai
j'aime naviguer planer dans l'univers
plus longtemps délicat entre chaque
épisode puis-je convaincu que ceux qui
côtoient des six elle faisait proposez
vous pourrez l'écouter au complet je
prends mon truc a dit qu'il ferait pas
parce qu'ils se rendent compte que comme
je disais tantôt le côté communautaire
le côté on en passe et réseaux sociaux
c'est une grosse partie du plaisait puis
la cité le
le fait que le monde l'écouté de façon
échelonnée se faire en sorte que tout le
côté parallèle au divertissement
on appela cote qui ont dit des
niaiseries beloeil le pop
je pense le mans se rendrait compte je
l'écouté à mon rythme il faut forcément
une des affaires aussi ses émissions
leur qui ont des quotidiennes
c'est que sim et ont écouté botha boot
les émissions sans l'espèce de ternir ma
réputation de après la pause ou en
revenant de dimanche ça durerait pas
être dix minutes paris tu enlèves les
publicités je t'enlève les dernières
meubles et les call back et écoute
toujours d'une tête à ce rythme et on
après la pause le si la meilleure chose
d'occupation double c'est ce qui fait le
show tant qu'à moi parce que tu vois
après la pause s'est jamais vraiment si
près de coire contexte plus nombreuses
qui voit tout mais jean l'excitation que
ça
mais j'avais quand même question
jusqu'au mobilier mais ouais c'est ça
fait que pour un enjeu j'espère j'espère
le faire un jour mais de tout de suite
des retours de la prod ce qu'ils étaient
et ce qu'ils savent que tu existes ce
que je ne sais pas en fait j'ai pas eu
de juin accusé réception
c'est un truc automatique ange envoyé
mes vidéos mais mes amis ce qu'ils m'ont
dit si tu prends ça va du nouvel abonné
portes qu'en mai moi ce qui me gisèle le
faux j'ai dit à mon ami je garde ça
dérange c'est parce qu'au début je
voulais pas faire ça me dérange c'est
d'envoyer ma vidéo parce que lui il
aimait vraiment pire jusqu'à ce soir des
nouvelles
ça dérange tu de l'envoyer à quelqu'un
de plus haut placé dans la preuve parce
que des contacts points j'ai pas encore
demandé mais c'est mon intention
chrissy nous écoute non mais en fait
c'est que moi je ce qui me stresse c'est
que j'ai l'impression que ma vidéo et
veracruz je peux me tromper mais je
pourrais toujours tomber sur quelqu'un
peu comme avec mon humour au québec qui
comprend pas un peu la folie la visite
pia parle partout via les arabes cdpc
foule ces facteurs qui est ce test à
déranger avec tomber sur une personne
qui a pas ce qu'ils doivent s'expliquer
l'etape j'ai enroulé les livres you la
personne qui fait le premier tri de
moissy entry après une minute et demie
et on dirait je trouverais ça plate que
juste parce qu'une personne potro saisi
langue meutri alors je fais comme je
pense aux troupes d'étape et aboutir un
peu plus haut un processus de la
pression que les autres seraient
intéressés mais bon des contacts mais
vous avez vous eu des contacts sexuels
et l'oder et oui tout le monde est
content
c'est dangereux bien huaxi nicole et
aucune chance clé du contact
non en fait je connais même pas cette
émission choc la toile parce que je vais
me rendre naturellement se rapproche le
crayon et là ballons du micro est
quelque chose que je trouve ça ma wii u
de l'ada je peux quand ça ternit qu'on
revienne quand s'éternise son style je
trouve ce audrey samra plus lieu d'être
regardé ce qui est de regarder jo de
portneuf
comment est ce que je sais c'est mal
mais je n'ai pas qu'à des taxes et moi
ça m'a angoissé profondément fait je
faisais stop parce que moi je me dis que
coach et samatan dort jamais je veux
dormir les gens que je m'endorme exemple
non mais mais j'ai écouté des vidéos
mais cette fois c'étaient des déchets
pour qui si on est des gens patients qui
fait des vidéos des vidéos genre de 12
heures sur youtube des affaires
justement parce qu'ils se disent vont
faire des vidéos assez long bon meublé
l'animal puis là c'est comme s'amender
bruit blanc puis des gants mais on
dirait que le fait que gelée que je vois
que ça dure 12 hors jeu compliqué on
réduit au tout petit jeu les couteaux
complet mais non mais l'aspect visuel
est vraiment mieux un truc je change
plus de 10,6 fin à base de vie qui un
peu comme nicole dit tantôt c'est
mettons que parce que moi j'écoute plus
des trucks ou sur youtube ou sur mon
ordi on sait que ça m'angoisse le monde
d'ailleurs
moi je me suis acheté un un loup pour
dormir
autre qualité propre oncle
la lumière rentrer le site allemand
s'appelle manta slip mnt a pu aussi
vendre des machines qui font que qui
font des bruits comme sur le hockey je
fais juste mettre sur le côté puis c'est
pas ton salaire c'est pas ton ordi c'est
une machine qui a des bruits programme
est à l'intérieur
je fais juste posé là dessus puis tu
peux mettre détails mais je suis ça jury
s'intéresse je vais adapter sa voix tout
à fait à leur dignité
sans commentaire il sponsorise pas
l'épisode manteau slip avantage parce
que moi aussi j'ai faux pas qui tu de
clarté mais il est vraiment les
meilleurs loup pour courir ce métier ou
autre question est ce qu elle parce que
je sais jamais capable d' occulter le
fait que j'aie jeune mathias au milieu
sont tous fait est vraiment confortable
hockey est vraiment confortable il ya en
même bleu je pense qu'on va conclure on
vote parce qu' on s'éloigne ainsi une
conversation intéressante de podcasts
mais il ya en vendre moi si tu peux
mettre dans le congélateur
le tulle mains sur tes yeux pis ces
frais au québec pour ses mots mer pas de
calais sa vie cette expérience parce que
je bosse avec des outils d août la date
centre et la tondeuse fota par la cabab
le chef est votre combat ils votent à le
vendre
j'espère qu'ils abordent le chef aux
cobras les chefs vous entendrez femme
qui aimait mme wable au wall ag à chaque
fois je l'aï vu je subirai donnait déjà
fait un pas de casse ensemble de david
bocage
il y avait fait un truc pas ou fès david
ou au cash podcast de résultats puis
c'était le terrain venez parler d'une
passion atypique sur la croissance début
mai
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans un podcast
ensemble c'était super sympathique le
sport comme moi j'entame un merci au cou
mais venus film on peut construire la
fac de lettres truth est choquée qui
marche est encore un trou vous étiez
quand que vous avez ça va être la fin de
pau 4 le plus d'or de l'histoire des ces
ihu qui travaillent et qui l'attentât
dont certains non les jeux dormez dormez
les deux les 2h30 et ma foi qu'il filme
mais tout est éveillée puis je te
réveiller en position d'attaqué avec des
lunettes fumées 1 bat puis je voulais
écouter des offices fakty je t'ai je
t'ai bien le puits le même ton vieux
québec connaît aussi infinie de
personnes qui habitent dans ce coin ils
ont connu l immersion dans mes jambes je
connais honnêtement des centaines de
personnes qui habitent à québec dans ce
coin lounge et qui circulent dans ce
coin-là puis puis quand c'est tombé le
genre je t'ai je les fais que j'ai pas
croire fort comment réagir comme
j'essayais d'aller prendre un bain j'ai
mis mon celle de ce que j'ai vu mettons
un gars bien en samouraï est recherché
en ce moment restez chez vous il ya tué
deux personnes et en a blessé cinq
j'imagine que je lise allaire un peu
dingue hein moi je vois ça je me dis si
leur lwin c'est sûr c'est pas vrai c'est
que là je me dis je vois pas paniquer je
parlais dans mon bain source mumbai me
suis dit quand je sortais nombreux ça va
être réglé
finalement j'ai repris mon ciel plus le
tout les médias s'en sont emparés tout
le monde parlait que de ça j'allais sur
rdi le pendant deux heures qu'ils
cherchaient j'étais genre temps battre
en batterie trembler puis j'ai regardé
l'écran
j'essaie d'écrire tout le monde que je
connais qui est tout simplement la
crèche et vous je sais pas ce qu'a
intenté gelé effectué pas j'essaie de
gérer ça mais le père la pire maintenant
j'aime ça
ça a été un très mauvais moment aussi
chez mes parents québec puis moi j'aï
seuls les films d'horreur gens
n'écoutent pas vraiment gosse puis puis
je me suis rappelé
on écoute et puis je me suis dit
pourquoi je me frustre et bref on
négocie à plus d'un film français
s'appelle grave c'est comme une fine
végétarienne à manger la viande cela
devient cannibale parce que comme ça tu
figure quelque chose en réel perd le
goût de manger demain c'est dark pisser
serov le film finit plus celle à qui
quand rudy salles le je me sentais mal
pour quelqu'un m'en vois ce meurtrier de
morts cinq blessés à l'armé blanche en
cavale puis comme toi je pensais que tu
es un prince
si je pensais que c'était une blague
c'est l'halloween puis le google
rapidement je me rends compte que c'est
vrai piti le jeter à québec c'était me
laisser l'information que j'avais été en
haute ville soit encore recherchée
j'étais en haute ville puis le le
mélange de ce puits le film qui venait
juste ramener j'étais en panne et
complète
jorge aibar et toutes les portes je
regardais par la fenêtre et quelqu'un
georges descendu en bas dans le noir
barré la porte en bois pige à peut-être
joué à voir quelqu'un le lobant la fnath
et la de la fenêtre la porte c'est sûr
puis ça a été vraiment le une nuit
horrible j'avais réellement vraiment pas
répéter si québec ces petits buts est le
il ya des personnes qui sont mortes
victimes et en anglais c'est de me
demory les chances que je connaisse
quelqu'un là-bas ils sont bien trop
élevés pipi comme de fait une victime si
l'oncle a une âme il atteint je te
laisse également petit que ce soit qui
ait mettons à une personne interposée
je veux connaître une personne qui sait
ce type existaient d'école c'est
vraiment horrible j'ai vu qu'il voulait
histoire épouvantable pour le reste
épouvantable mais comme tous les
professeurs sur une lourdeur je veux
raconter quelque chose peut-être car nos
cerveaux comptage raconte ça mais
c'est juste parce que c'est tellement
pas de sa faute si c'était tellement pas
volontaire mais je veux pas s'est
assoupi c'est peut-être en deçà plus
léger plus léger mais juste de
comprendre non mais mon père nous on
fait des corps au sol y ont fait des
copains on line où on anime des genres
de soi des cinq à sept ou dix on est
comme un peu sur the past three miami
c'est intelligent son chèque et chats
que jésus petit rond on leur parle on
les a vécu commun aux deux lignes
ouvertes mais corpo numérique mais
tanguy
comment fais tu pour des entreprises là
c'était pour une école puis c'était
avant-hier je pense
puis arnaud il ya plein de props
accident un stade plein propre chez eux
dans son aura son décor dans son art son
sous-sol ses enfants puis moi j'avais
quand même je me suis mis un j'avais
tout lyon chez nous fait que j'étais
comme fait comme si le lion m'étrangler
booster les alouettes jeudi genre je
suis déguisé en déguisé en argot qui se
fait présentement asphyxie par un lion
mais qui dit le diable parce que c'était
comme un gag pour arnaud y signa sorti
plein de gains il ya pogné une épée en
plastique des signes afin d'y move dp
gens parlent du second pour nier c'est
la 31e c'était là un c'était jean deux
jours après guy clerc marc nollet stag
histoire principale était qu'il faut
juste qu'on change le jeu ou que je
disais rien parce que si je l'accuse le
cp puis comme des élèves qui écoute des
profs la direction et l homme te sentir
mal à l'aise ou non j'ai pas sorti de
mares parce que je crains tel marne aube
je sais qu'il y avait aussi au juste
papa c'est une personne qui a dressé ces
personnes-là dressé mais aussi qu'on ne
finit le stream dire encore la direction
ce plu j'ai fait un joker d'eau puisque
les élèves ne voyez plus les ont été
jusqu'à 1,5 six personnes que toute la
direction était vraiment emballé par le
corpus à bienne et il pleut il mouille à
eminem pascal magnier shenzhen a une
fille
ap allen n'en ont parlé de natation des
étudiantes qui sort de la classe non là
on y parle là jeudi à fait nous fait
montre nous ton croll un creux
raisonnement et plus j'ai maintenu mon
tout à brasse et pottas brassier avant
tout à 50 centimes mais souvent fait que
le arnaud après-midi imminente mais
c'était juste drôle de monde
bon tout ça brasse la brassière seul
échappé cheveux comme christine bouquet
de canal totaux tabac peut y a comme
allumer et fait un pas mais tu voyais à
sa phase que ça y est même temps c'est
juste c'est trop trop collé un mois plus
tard mais lost et gens tellement frais
ça dans la tête de tout le monde et
arnaud yoke système argos sensible et
aucune chance mais mais pour moi c'était
comme quelque chose qui ces mots quand
même fait rire lassés de la situation et
de lourdeurs et de tristesse mais le
fait que le fait qu'arnaud se rendent
pas compte qu'ils fassent bible car à
défaut le catalogue de 80 des ja nos
amis stan mikita la création double
renault
et puis on joue toutes les semaines avec
lui à donjons dragons ici même le tir
qui sous un tipi médiévale puis à odetti
effet des doubles des médiévales
politiques hommes étaient un peu raides
comme le gars qui trippent médiéval près
c'est monseigneur ahouana pluie
s'installe g apprécié des consulats jack
hillen journée de l'halloween it et
déguisés en chevaliers juste avec une
moustache le médiéval de ce tableau s'il
ya besoin je suis l'exemple médiévale
classée leterme qui était repris dans
tous les médias y un doute d'exemple
métier
le tout voilà ma y arrive c'est
comprendre les blagues clio fabriquées
pour mon live ce soir je ne serai pas
habillée du style médiéval excellent
mieux pas mal moins 6 et le arnaud je me
raconte que gilles dit qu'à date à
catane oui mais là c'est à cause que je
suis le lauquet et les sénateurs jouent
canada ah ah oui c'est vrai donc c'est
pour ça j'ai forcément ses syllabes
ces bombes à des formations
professionnelles sportives s'est éteint
un grand fan de spectacle controversé
doit par la page aussi à nicole de la
retraite le mot de la fac parce que à ce
moment tat à 12 interventions talent
avait fait douze dans un des épisodes
précédents je veux tu passes ta 13ème et
aux anciens ma troisième intervention
c'est assez ça suffit pour moi ben en
fait je pense que là tu vois juste
offrir mes sympathies au monde et aux
victimes
absolument et c'est vrai de toute une
pensée pour les victimes et des victimes
collatérales et québec
je te les vieux qui ont mené lundi des
besoins annoncé lundi puis des besoins
juste le feeling peut-être mon sentiment
moi même par rapport à la ville mais
aussi avait une espèce de vague vraiment
besoin la beauté du vieux-québec versus
l'orage et 5,5 lâche jacques roux blanc
vraiment petit québec sq
somme toute c'est une ville consent
sécurité est une ville que c'est son
sens chine où on se promène dans la rue
pour la plupart touchent pas une femme
attend le plus beau métier
j'ai pas les gens me font confiance je
sais que ça arrive c'est juste ça vient
ternir un peu si landry sera ma poche ça
fait comme deux tragédies vraiment
horrible laquelle [ __ ] merci merci
[Rires]
merci et agréable enfin pas si vite mais
il faut pour arriver très tabou
[Rires]